Hast du sonst noch irgendwas
cooles gefunden? Ich habe vorhin noch mal
durch den
wie haben wir den Raum genannt? Linkdump
Weißt du was?
Wenn ich eine Notification kriege, dass
du da was reingeschrieben hast und ich klicke die Notification
an, dann komme ich auf diesen Raum und er ist leer.
Ich sehe dann dort nichts. Schreib mal
bitte was in den Linkdump. Danke Element
für gar nichts. Also Linkdump
Quatsch. Element fühlt sich für mich immer noch
wie sowas Halbfertiges an.
Was ist das denn?
Na? So.
Was passiert, wenn du auf dieses Banner
umgehst, Jump to First?
So. Offenbar. Wahrscheinlich ist
dann einfach das nicht, vielleicht ist das dann
zu lange her und der zeigt mir, wenn ich nicht
sofort drauf klicke oder sowas, zumindest
ist das manchmal...
Ah, Kilian hat was geschrieben und dann sehe ich...
Ich weiß auch echt nicht, wie Element lokal die History
hält, weil ich meine,
also es sollte doch mit Textnachrichten kein
Problem sein, alles in den Lokal in eine
SQLite-Datenbank zu kippen und das für immer
assistieren. Bilddaten kannst du
irgendwo mal rauspunen, wenn du möchtest oder andere Sachen.
Ich habe gekämpft, hier ein Bild einzufügen
in unserem Chat, als ich das mit diesem
komischen Grill posten wollte.
Da war
mein erstes, wo war es, ist das schon seitdem
so viel passiert? Ne.
Diese Fotos wollte ich posten. Was war das Erste, was
passiert ist? Ich poste diese URLs und
dann hat er das hier.
Aber nicht mal die ganze URL erkannt.
Da hatte die URL irgendwo.
War da Sternchen drin oder was?
Da waren Unterstriche, bestimmt.
Eventuell, die haben
haben keinen anständigen,
die haben keinen richtigen URL-Pauser.
Oder ich meine, das ist halt ein
Amazon-Link, das ist ein Bild von
Amazon, die haben eh komische URLs.
Ja, aber trotzdem, du solltest nicht innerhalb von
einer URL-Unterstriche als Markdown pausen.
Da ist definitiv das falsch gelaufen.
Es gibt ja auch so Sachen, wo du manchmal Code-Beispiele
postest und dann tauchen
mittendrin, obwohl das als Code geheilitet
wird, trotzdem smiley ist auf.
Ich halte das.
Du denkst dir so, ja, Emoticons
sind cool, aber
Es ist 2021.
Vor allem Doppelpunkt, Klammer zu, hat man nicht so
selten in diversen Sprachen.
Das sollte bitte nicht so ein Smiley
werden. Tatsächlich.
So, okay. Wir sind jetzt hier schon
bereits im Aufnahmemodus
und das ist Routing,
ist jetzt hier Routing für
Pre-Show für Aufnahme.
Bitte, bitte.
Die Folgeansicht und dann kann man
so einen Tick rauszoomen.
So, hast du dir GitHub-Drama angeguckt?
Ich habe ein paar davon gelesen.
Ich bin überhaupt nicht dazu gekommen.
Ein paar sind wirklich sehr unterhaltsam.
Man kann es nicht ansprechen,
aber ich weiß nicht,
da ist nichts dabei, was ich wirklich rausziehen sollte oder wollte.
Ich habe nicht alle gelesen,
denen ja wirklich viele.
Aber manche Leute echauffieren sich einfach so schön über gar nichts.
Oder andere haben so ein bisschen mehr Tiefe plötzlich.
Du hast zum einen mal so ein Thread von Leuten,
die sich darüber beschweren,
dass Steam vor Linux broken ist,
weil sie ein Wack-Ban bekommen.
also diese geschützten Server von Valve,
die Cheater verhindern sollen.
Die haben dieses VAC-System.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wofür VAC steht.
Du kommst auf jeden Fall gebannt von VAC
oder du kriegst eine Account-Sperre,
wenn du Bots benutzt oder so.
Valve Anti-Cheat.
Okay.
Verständlich.
Macht Sinn.
Und angeblich lässt sich Steam for Linux
schaut mit auf deinen Username
und mit deinem Username
was war es, irgendwas mit Cat
weißt du, gab es irgendwie so
ein Cheatbot-Software, Catbot, genau,
Catbot, war irgendwie so ein Cheat
für Team Fortress oder was auch immer
und wenn dein Username
Catbot ist oder Catbot enthält, kriegst
du ein Vagband in Steam
und der Third haben sich halt mal haufen, weil es Leute
eigentlich so viel drüber, dass das ja nicht geht
die ganzen Leute, die alle Catbot heißen
oder Scatbot anscheinend einer
oder sonst was, aber
ja, das wäre ein dummes Issue
und irgendwann wurde das halt ein bisschen ominös geschlossen
und weil Werf angeblich gesagt hat,
dass sie Wack-Issues nicht auf GitHub besprechen
und dann hat jemand auch drunter
einen Link zum, ich glaube,
ein Forum oder was war das gepostet,
Steve-Support-Forum oder irgendwas anderes,
wo Werf bloß gesagt hat, hier,
das ist kein Issue, dieses Issue existiert nicht,
die ganzen Scammer und
Cheater versuchen nur uns zu
und das Vertrauen
wegzubissbrauchen,
indem sie solche Issues erfinden,
die ein bisschen Community-Rialen dagegen
und da halt Drama
aufführen. Also anscheinend gab es dieses
Ich-You-Nie. Das war einfach nur eine dicke Lüge.
Ein Versuch, das zu anderminen.
Natürlich ist Werk ein geschlossenes System,
wo du nicht schauen kannst. Das ist halt wirklich
typisches, obskures, also du weißt nicht,
welche Regeln das fährt. Sollst du nicht wissen, weil es sonst
nicht so effektiv wäre.
Security durch Obscurity.
Ja, aber bei so einem System verstehe ich das, weil das halt
ein Katz-und-Maus-Dings ist, zu zittern,
daher zu rennen.
Du hast dann wenigstens einen gewissen Vorsprung.
Ja, aber wenn sie halt in dem Forum dann sagen,
dass ein Backbend nie kommt,
ganz sicher bei Design nicht,
wenn nicht das Spiel läuft und irgendwelche,
also nur wenn das Spiel läuft
gerade, werden überhaupt nach
Triggern geschaut und es gab nie einen Username-Trigger
oder so. Aber wenn das Spiel gar nicht läuft,
dann wird gar nicht nach Triggern geschaut, also war das ganze
Issue schon einfach mal nicht möglich.
Und wenn du da halt durchliest,
dann ist das doof,
die haben hier so richtig dumme
Sachen hier reingeschaut, die schauen auf die Usernames
und haben da irgendwelche Metriken draufgeworfen.
Nein, das ging dann plötzlich einen anderen
Twist gehabt, das fand ich witzig.
Oh Mann. Also GitHub-Drama
sollte ich mir mal angucken.
Aber ich meine, da gibt es noch echt andere Probleme.
Die Leute, die sich beschweren, dass der CatBot
als Name nicht valide ist.
Wenn jemand von einer Amerikanern
oder von Europäern entwickelten Seite
mit einem indischen Namen ankommt
und ihm da irgendwie gesagt wird, dein Name ist
invalide, obwohl der einfach bloß seinen ganz normalen Namen
da eingetippt hat, der ist halt nicht in das normale...
Das ist was anderes.
Als jemand mit dem Umlaut im Namen I can relate.
Ich habe das schon oft erlebt.
Ja, stimmt. Ich bin wenigstens froh, dass mein Name nur
ASCII-Zeichen enthält. Das ist angenehm.
Das ist angenehm.
Ich habe mir jetzt tatsächlich neulich auch mal wieder was von
Steam, überhaupt mal was von Steam gekauft,
weil ich irgendwie vor 100
Jahren mal Shank 2
bei so einem Humble Bundle gekauft habe
und durchgezockt habe und dann wollte ich mal
Shank 1 auf Steam kaufen.
Das ist so ein Sidescrawler, das ist so ein Rambo-Typ,
der einfach von links nach rechts rennt und
irgendwelche Goons aufs
übelste Vermöbel. Das ist supergeil.
Okay, kenn ich ja nicht.
Das ist wirklich so ein uriger
Sidescroller. Und dann hab ich mir das runtergeladen
hier auf meinem Spiele
Mac Mini und dann
Was?
Und dann
hatte ich das runtergeladen und dann sagt mir mein Computer
Ja, es ist schön, dass du das runtergeladen hast.
Das ist leider nur eine reine
32-Bit-Binary und die führe ich jetzt nicht mehr aus.
Also schon sogar bei Steam ist es
eine Mac-kompatible. Ja, das ist fast
von Mac-kompatible und ich hab mir gedacht, das ist aber schön
und jetzt sagt mein Mac mir aber
Da liegt übrigens Strom,
dieses Kabel hängt da frei. Das kannst du gerne
benutzen, links an der Seite.
Nicht das rote, sondern das weiße
da am Rand an der Seite.
Praktisch.
Da habe ich mich dann sehr gefreut
und dann habe ich mir gedacht, leck mich am Arsch.
Aber weil ich weiß, dass ich das Spiel ja ursprünglich nur
gespielt hatte, weil es auch mal auf Linux lief,
habe ich mir das dann einfach auf meinem Linux-Computer installiert und dort gespielt.
Okay, immerhin das.
Aber bei GOG gibt es das nicht, oder?
Keine Ahnung, so weit bin ich noch nicht.
Ich habe jetzt seit Weihnachten
sehr viele Spaziergänge in Minecraft gemacht
und fand es ein bisschen schade,
dass die ganzen Uni-Freunde von uns
diesen Minecraft-Server wahrscheinlich gar nicht mehr betreiben.
Zumindest habe ich keine Referenz dazu gefunden.
Dirk, falls du das jetzt hörst und der Minecraft-Server
noch läuft, sag mal bitte Bescheid.
Du, ich habe letztens eine coole Seite gefunden.
Die stellen kostenlose Minecraft-Server zur Verfügung.
Ah, nice.
Und die machen das ausschließlich...
Kann ich da die Welt, die ich jetzt bereits bei mir lokal spiele,
bereits importieren?
Die haben dir File-Zugriffe gegeben.
ich weiß nicht, ob du sowas hochladen kannst.
Ich hab schon relativ viel Diamanten
gesammelt jetzt.
Du klingst wie so ein Grundschüler.
Ich hab schon drei Nachmittage
reingesteckt. Das ist so viel Mühe,
die da sind.
Das lässt sich gut kombinieren, wenn du
dabei irgendwie Star Trek guckst oder
Audible hörst,
wenn eh Lockdown Winter ist
und du nichts machen kannst. Das stimmt, Minecraft braucht nicht so viel
geistige CPU-Cycles.
Nee, da rennt's einfach.
Wenn du irgendwo
um halb eins
da hockst und
irgendwie auf Level 11 unten
kurz vorm Boden irgendwie Strip-Mining
betreibst, um
Diamanten zu finden. Da kannst du nebenbei
einen Film gucken, ehrlich gesagt.
Das habe ich auch in dem Spiel auch immer am liebsten gemacht.
Einfach Strip-Mining durch den Boden
und bestenfalls noch irgendwelche unterirdischen
also von unten den
Ozean anbohren und dann
quasi Höhlen mit
Gläsern im Dach unterm Wasser bauen.
Das wäre immer das Coolste.
die ganzen anderen Schritte an dem Spiel, also
in den Nether gehe ich ungern oder ins End,
da habe ich ja noch gar nicht rausgefunden, wie ich das mache.
Ich habe auch letzte Woche zum ersten Mal überhaupt
was enchanted, weil ich,
und das ist auch ein bisschen, das ist nicht so gut
nicht so gut erlernbar
irgendwie, man muss sich ganz viel das Wiki angucken
oder YouTube-Pretory.
Ich glaube, es lebt davon, dass du YouTube-Pretory bist.
Ja, ich glaube auch.
Ich habe jetzt überhaupt geguckt, was ich mit so einem
Dropper überhaupt machen kann und was der soll
oder wie man einen Pisten bedient.
Ich habe tonnenweise Redstone rumliegen,
weiß gar nicht, was ich damit machen kann.
Jetzt werden mir wahrscheinlich Leute sagen, ah, du kannst
das krasse
hier Z8-Computer mitbauen
oder sowas. Das haben Leute ja vor 10 Jahren schon
in Minecraft gebaut. Ja, ja, aber ich weiß,
dass man irgendwie absurde
Maschinen bauen kann in Minecraft, aber das ist
nicht der Grund, warum ich Minecraft spiele, weil das mache ich den ganzen
Tag auf Arbeit schon. Ich glaube, das Krasse, was ich jemals
gebaut habe in Minecraft, ist so eine automatische Farm.
Das ist so ein kleines Feld, was halt dann
mit einem Pisten,
glaube ich, einen Wasserblock so frei macht
und das dann wegflutet
das spült quasi alles runter und dann hinten
in so eine Spalte und dann
in eine Kiste rein, irgendwie so war das.
Das ist auch schon eine ganze Weile her.
Das ist so der Grund, warum mein
GitHub-Graph gerade so ein bisschen nackig geworden ist,
weil ich irgendwie in letzter Zeit eher Minecraft
gespielt habe. Da gab es ja so eine schöne Seite.
Wie hieß die nochmal?
Achso, übrigens! Hi Kilian!
Hey Hendrik!
Willkommen bei Akronomisierbar
Folge 47
Wie geht's dir?
Gut, gut
Den Umspenden entsprechen, nee
Gut siehst du aus
Ja, die Corona-Frisur
Mich hat jetzt letzte Woche mein
Friseur angerufen
Mit dem Hinweis, wir sind übrigens
ab 1. März wieder offen
und wir sind jetzt umgezogen.
Okay.
Wollen Sie nicht jetzt schon einen Termin machen?
Wie beim Zahnarzt.
So einen kleinen Zettel dann.
Das finde ich super schön, dass ihr mich persönlich
angerufen habt und dass ihr mir das sagt.
Ich glaube nicht, dass ich bereits
am 1. März komme, weil ich mich so ein bisschen
selbst versorgt habe.
Sieht super gut aus.
Es geht, ne?
Die Leute sehen mich ja eh nur von vorne.
Dementsprechend ist das nicht so schlimm.
Aber ich werde dann wahrscheinlich auch mal
Mitte März wieder zum Friseur gehen. Was hast du da für eine
coole Seite? Weil wir gerade beim GitHub
Contribution Graph waren. Das ist skyline.github.com.
Da gibst du
deinen Username ein, kriegst deinen Contribution
Graph als
so ein kleines Model.
Das sieht meins wahrscheinlich eher wie so
Vorstadt aus.
Da wird es schon langsam dünn.
Aber du kannst es sicherlich das STL runterladen
und in 3D drucken und dir ins Regal stellen, wenn du
möchtest.
Ich hätte ja, wie gesagt, eher lieber
diese Fliesenleiste irgendwo
im Bad oder in der Küche.
Aber auf der anderen Seite, wie gesagt, mein GitHub-Graph
ist jetzt nichts, wo ich momentan
irgendwie viel mit punkten könnte,
weil ich es eher am Wochenende nutze.
Prinzipiell war mein GitHub-Graph schon immer
hier so ein weirdes
Angeb-Feature, aber es ist ein schönes
Feature, was diese, auch mit
das Gefühl von GitHub
gemacht hat. Man sieht da halt
diese grünen Graphen da. Ich finde es geil, wenn du
in den Dark Mode gehst, dann sieht es einfach aus wie die Matrix.
Ja, der Graph ist schick,
aber ich muss sagen, ich finde den Darkmoon von GitHub unglaublich hässlich.
Ich weiß auch nicht, wieso.
Vielleicht ist es die blauen Links da.
Irgendwas stört mich daran.
Ich habe lange gewartet, einen Darkmoon für GitHub
zu bekommen, habe ihn introduced, habe ihn angeschaut.
Nope. I don't like this.
Das geht eigentlich.
Ich finde es okay. Ich finde es lustig, dass der Hintergrund
und diese Buttons irgendwie mit einer unterschiedlichen
Geschwindigkeit umschalten.
Wenn du mal guckst, der Button ist immer so ein bisschen
hinterher, wenn du umschaltest.
Witzig.
Gut, ja, was haben wir denn heute für ein cooles Themenportfolio vorbereitet, Kean?
Wir haben uns viel hin und her geschickt über die letzten Monate an Sachen, die so passiert sind.
Wir haben es schon wieder eine Weile nicht mehr gemacht.
Ich glaube, ziemlich genau einen Monat her.
Ist gar nicht so lang her, oder?
Nee, warte.
Ich wollte eigentlich diese Folge anfangen.
Ach, und übrigens, diesmal zu Gast ist und dann so Cricket-Geräusche einspielt.
Ich fand ja nicht so ein Tumbleweed-Geräusch.
Ach nee, Quarantäneheldin war die letzte Folge.
Genau.
Am 10. Das ist 40 Tage her.
Das war eine gute Folge.
Also mit Tom müssen wir eigentlich
nochmal was machen.
Auf jeden Fall.
Diesmal würde ich gerne mal
auf ein, zwei Sachen eingehen. Wir haben ja diesen
unwahrscheinlich schönen
akronomisierbaren Matrix-Channel,
wo unsere tollsten Fans und wahrscheinlich
auch Leute, die gar nicht, wahrscheinlich ein paar Leute,
die überhaupt nicht wissen, was akronomisierbar überhaupt ist,
aber uns ab und zu
Themen schicken.
Schönen Gruß an unseren Chat.
Da kommt auch, ich weiß nicht, inwiefern du das
jetzt dann schneidest oder nicht,
da kommt ja auch der GitHub-Drama-Link
vom Eugen her, der hat das damit reingeschmissen
vor ein paar Tagen,
das wir ja vorhin gerade mal angesprochen
hatten, je nachdem, ob das noch eine Folge
gibt oder nicht.
Also ich meine, es gibt ja immer mal so Geschichten,
wo dann so Diskussionen,
Softwareentwicklung ist ja ein unwahrscheinlich
emotionales Metier,
wo dann, ich weiß noch
wie es hochgekocht ist,
und diese Begriffe, die ich jetzt verwenden werde,
werden darauf hinweisen, wie lange das her ist,
als bei Rails zum ersten Mal
als Default Coffee Script eingeführt wurde.
Da gab es dann auch Diskussionen darüber
auf dem Pull Request.
I smell a fork.
Und diese Leute sich aufgeregt haben.
Und kannst du dir das jetzt noch vorstellen?
Du meinst so ein Drama oder Coffee Script?
CoffeeScript zu benutzen und Rails.
Ich habe auch heute erst durch
ein paar GitHub-Drama-Sachen gescrollt,
irgendwo CoffeeScript. Ach, das war in Bezug auf Atom.
Atom war ja zu großen Teilen auch,
glaube ich, in CoffeeScript geschrieben.
Habe mich zurückerinnert.
Ich glaube, meine CoffeeScript-Zeit waren
so Sachen, die ich für so ein Hubot,
so ein von GitHub entschriebenes
Bot-Framework, so ein Stackbot,
habe ich sehr viele Sachen in CoffeeScript geschrieben.
Ich fand auch CoffeeScript total schön,
als es da war.
Hauptsächlich, weil mich auch
von JavaScript, was ja damals noch
ES3 war,
so angekotzt hat.
Aber rückwirkend
bereue ich bei zum Beispiel diesem
Naubino, was ich mit Gilbert gebaut habe, bereue ich
eigentlich das schon benutzt.
Ich wollte das seitdem mal irgendwie wieder
modernisieren und aufhecken. Ich habe es zweimal versucht
und ich kriege einfach diesen Code nicht mehr gelesen.
Es ist nicht so viel gedacht, dass man...
Hasen im Kopf.
Ja, ja, und es ist auch nicht...
Gut, okay, wir haben uns da auch nicht so viel.
Wir haben es vielleicht auch ein bisschen komisch
architektonisch aufgezogen.
Ich meine, gut, es ist schade, dass das CoffeeScript,
also ich hänge
jetzt nicht so in der Community drin, schon gar nicht eigentlich
in der JS-Welt, so wie du. Ich weiß
nicht, ob CoffeeScript noch lebt oder nicht, aber es fühlt sich
irgendwie so an. Es gibt CoffeeScript 2.0 und das ist
das, ja, ja, und das
ist auch eigentlich, wenn
du dir so anguckst, denkst du dir so,
das ist eigentlich ganz schick, aber die Sachen, die CoffeeScript
geil gemacht haben, die brauchst,
die sind eigentlich nicht mehr, für
meine persönliche Empfindung, nicht mehr
unbedingt erstrebenswert, also
es hat halt zum ersten Mal diese
File-Funktions-Syntax mitgebracht, das war halt
wirklich was, was es in JavaScript noch nicht gab, da musstest du immer
wie viele Zeichen hat, Function
7, 8, musstest du halt dir das mal
ausschreiben überall, da hast du überall dieses lange
Function-Keyboard gehabt und das kannst du dir hier sparen, es gab
es gibt Thin und
Fat-Arrows in
Also mit Strich und ist gleich?
Mit Strich und ist gleich, wo ein
Thin-Arrow ist ein Function
und ein Fat-Arrow ist ein
JavaScript auch ein Fat-Arrow, also mit
Binding oder nicht und so weiter
ansonsten hast du halt so Short-Syntax,
die so ein bisschen YAML-esk aussieht.
Ich finde, es hat
zur Zeit vieles richtig gemacht
und hat JavaScript angenehmer und cooler gemacht.
Aber es wurde halt,
also generell hat sich die JavaScript-Welt
in eine gute Richtung weiterentwickelt
und ist ja nicht stehen geblieben
auf dem maligen Stand.
Auch gerade was Typescript mit angeht.
Das ist ja auch ein unglaublich großes Ding,
was viel mitgebracht hat
für das ganze Ecosystem.
Auf jeden Fall. Wobei wir bei
der Themen aus dem Matrix-Chat wären.
Ja, gute Überleitung.
Erzähl mal, ich habe mir das nämlich nicht
angeschaut. Also ich weiß jetzt noch gar
nicht, um was es hier geht.
Ich habe den Artikel nicht durchgelesen. Der Artikel heißt
A Post Mortem in Five Acts, How Microsoft
Privatized Open Source and Killed JavaScript in the
Process. Ja, das ist halt ein ziemlich
reißerisch geschriebenes und das ist tatsächlich
gar nicht mal so alt. Das ist wirklich vom 11.
Es hat einen riesigen
Wolf. Ja, natürlich, es hat einen übelsten
Wolf und das
ist halt Anti-Microsoft
habe ich jetzt nichts gegen, also das ist halt
eine Riesenfirma, kann man auch was dagegen haben,
aber was dir geschrieben wird,
ist halt, glaube ich, so ein bisschen
übertrieben.
Die postulieren, dass Microsoft ein JavaScript
übernommen hat, die haben einen Takeover.
Die haben quasi die gesamte Open-Source-Community
damit zerstört, mit dem, was sie hier machen.
Das ist das Argument, okay.
Das ist so das Argument und es ging halt los
mit
When I started coding,
Also man merkt, dass das eine sehr persönliche Geschichte ist.
I really love the open source JavaScript community.
It did always feel weird that people would write code
and share it for free,
but people did and still do
and it felt amazing and crazy at the same time.
There was GitHub to manage your open source and NPM,
which indexed the open source libraries
and it made it super easy to search,
find and import functionalities
and to create, update and share libraries ourselves.
on Stack Overflow, you
could even get free support
and advice.
JavaScript was improving
year after year with every
ECMAScript release. It was perfect,
but it all worked.
It wasn't perfect, but it all worked. The future
seemed bright. Also hier möchte ich
schon mal irgendwie reingrätschen,
was der hier
als seine
Idealzeit als schöne Vergangenheit
beschreibt, war bereits der Untergang von Open Source
für Leute, die zehn Jahre vorher angefangen haben
weil plötzlich alles auf GitHub war.
Und NPM, die Geschichte von NPM ist auch eine Geschichte voller Missverständnisse,
ehrlich gesagt.
Das ist eine Firma, die sich um Node gegründet hatte,
was auch schon eine Sache war,
die nicht wirklich viel direkt mit JavaScript,
sondern mit einem eigenen Projekt zu tun hatte.
Und NPM war von Anfang an als kommerzielle Firma gegründet,
die irgendwie so an der Seite zwar von vielen gemocht
und auch sehr nützlich gewesen ist,
aber trotzdem nicht Open Source,
sondern Geld machen als Prämisse hatte.
Ähnliches gilt halt auch für Stack Overflow.
Also du kriegst da Free Advice, das ist schön.
Es gibt aber auch Leute, die irgendwie traumatisiert
aus so Stack Overflow-Konversionen wieder rauskommen.
Das ist alles...
Ich meine, das halten ja viele Leute auch auf GitHub rum,
dass das ja alles so zentralisiert und zusammenbringt.
Aber ich glaube, GitHub hat trotzdem sehr viel
für die Open-Source-Welt getan, auch auf der anderen Seite.
Also ohne GitHub, ich meine, Git an sich ist ja schön dezentral.
Du schenkst ja GitHub nichts mit deinem Code.
Natürlich, du hast deine privaten Repos, Microsoft hat theoretisch Zugang zu deinen privaten Repos, das ist natürlich ein bisschen schwierig, damit musst du klarkommen, wenn du private Sachen auf GitHub legst, die nicht für Microsofts Augen bestimmt sind.
Wenn du damit leben kannst, dann ist das deine Entscheidung.
Aber gerade dieser öffentliche Zugang, den GitHub ermöglicht und gerade auch diverse Package-Manager, die ihre Datenbanken, also ihre Specs, Repos und was auch immer, auf GitHub legen und wo GitHub mehrfach schon gesagt hat, also ich kenne das jetzt von CocoaPods für die iOS-Entwicklung, für generell die DAO-Entwicklung und von Homebrew, den MacOS-Package-Manager, dass GitHub da schon öfter mal in die Issues kam, hey, wir sind committed zum kostenlosen Hosten von dem für immer, aber hier sind ein paar Änderungen, die wir machen müssten, weil aktuell haben wir drei Server, die nur euer Repo hosten.
drei dedizierte Maschinen dafür.
Also ich meine, das ist glaube ich so eine der ersten
Geschichten, die wir in diesem Podcast
Das kann gut sein, kann gut sein, aber sowas ist halt
natürlich kostet das Geld, so eine Infrastruktur zu hosten
und es ist schön, dass es eine Firma zahlt
und das halt in dem Fall für solche Sachen
ohne Gegenleistung, also die CocoaPod
beziehungsweise Homebrew-Leute müssen, soweit ich weiß,
nicht an GitHub abtreten dafür
und die entwickeln ihre Projekte weiter und GitHub
enabled, dass diese Projekte so
existieren und es wäre natürlich schön, wenn
andere Leute, also wenn, keine Ahnung, Apple mit
Geld auf sowas werfen würde, damit Homeware weiterlebt,
weil für Apple ist das sehr relevant, dass Homeware existiert,
auch wenn das Apple nach außen
hin nicht so auswirken lässt, aber sich trifft sich ein bisschen
ab. Aber GitHub hat meiner Meinung nach sehr viel
getan, auch für die Open-Source-Welt.
Wir würden sonst heute wahrscheinlich noch auf
Source-Forge leben.
Ja, also hier steht auch noch,
although Open-Source grew inside of Capitalism,
its values weirdly weren't
part of that capitalistic worldview.
Das ist halt diese, was er ja auch
beschreibt, sind Zeiten, wo
GitHub und NPM neu waren und irgendwie
noch nicht ganz so profitabel sein mussten
und es wahrscheinlich auch nicht waren und dann irgendwann
ist halt der Punkt eingetreten, wo es dann hieß,
naja, also langsam müsstet ihr doch mal Geld produzieren
und dann sind halt so
ein bisschen hartere Entscheidungen gefehlt.
Aber er gibt ja auch, ich meine, irgendwo, ich meine, er kann natürlich
auch Services bauen, die kein Geld generieren,
wo Leute hobbymäßig Zeit reinstecken.
Das kann super funktionieren, da gibt es genügend Beispiele,
aber wenn du halt Leute hast, die sowas
fulltime supporten, die wollen
ja auch von irgendwas leben und
dann hast du halt ein Kollektiv und
Vielleicht läuft das halt, dann machst du halt eine Firma draus und die will halt auch Geld verdienen, damit man das ausbauen kann, indem man mehr Leute hiert, indem man andere Ressourcen mit draufschmeißt.
Dann wird das Ganze gekauft von irgendwem. Also natürlich hat das irgendwo eine Entwicklung.
Vorher war eh schon, wie du machst, Open Source. Open Source ist so das böse Modell. Eigentlich sollte man ja Free Software machen.
Open Source ist ja nur das, was von den Kapitalisten gefördert wird,
weil Open Source ist nämlich das, wo alle ihre Arbeitszeit verschenken
und wir das einfach benutzen können,
ohne dass wir irgendwie so blöde GPL-Lizenzen dafür verwenden müssen.
Das ist ja nochmal die Ausbaustufe mehr.
So, jetzt geht's hier weiter.
Then one day Microsoft came in and took control of the two core tools,
which were the gateways to the whole Open Source Community.
NPM and GitHub.
Und ich erst mal so, Moment.
Moment. Erstens,
the gateways to the whole open source
community, NPM und
GitHub. Als jemand, der sehr wenig NPM
nutzt, fühle ich mich hier vor nicht angesprochen.
Ja,
so, ich hab mir, ich hab tatsächlich,
obwohl ich
Vollzeit mein Geld mit TypeScript verdiene, hab ich mir
letzte Woche überhaupt erstmal einen NPM
Account freigeschalten.
So, die
kommen also rein und nehmen Kontrolle.
Das NPM irgendwie
fort... Warte mal,
GitHub hatte finanzielle
Probleme und hat sich dann gefreut, dass
sie von Microsoft gekauft wurden. Da haben sich noch
alle gewundert, oh, Microsoft, wir haben
akronomisierbar berichtete.
Alle so,
alle so, okay, Microsoft hat
jetzt GitHub gekauft, wir
gehen mal lieber weg und dann ist halt GitLab
irgendwie noch ein Stückchen gewachsen.
Aber im Endeffekt,
im Endeffekt war es nicht so schlimm.
Naja, du weißt halt, also,
Was halt für uns passiert ist, ist GitHub, also ich glaube eine der größten Auswirkungen davon waren plötzlich, dass GitHub Actions existiert haben, die mich betreffen, weil Microsoft da halt haufenweise Geld und die Azure Cloud dahinter geschmissen hat.
Das ist wahrscheinlich eher schlecht für so Leute wie Travis.
Ja, sicherlich. Also für Travis war das wahrscheinlich richtig scheiße, dass GitHub gekauft wurde.
Und das ist halt ein Teil dieser Zentralisierung, den man durchaus auch kritisieren kann.
Also ich muss sagen, ich habe auch Sachen von Travis auf GitHub Actions umgestellt.
Ich nutze noch GitHub Actions.
Aber ich meine, diese Zentralisierung kann man ja ansprechen, aber es ist ja nicht so, als ob du die Sachen nicht auch woanders machen könntest.
Ich meine, von dem Core-Git-Repo, das ist ja wirklich das Dezentralste, was geht, was ich vorhin meinte.
Du kannst deinem Depot einfach einen anderen Remote geben und woanders hin pushen.
Was halt wirklich zentralisiert ist, sind meistens die Issues und die Pull-Requests.
Die kannst du theoretisch exportieren und sicherlich mit Tools woanders importieren, aber das ist nicht so.
Das ist ein Problem, das gab es bei GitHub schon bevor
Microsoft eingestiegen ist.
Eben, das ist ein Problem,
in Anführungsstrichen, weil das Git halt
nicht beinhaltet. Es gibt Leute, die bauen das halt
in solche Tools, die sowas mit
in das Repo reinpatchen. Finde ich weird, aber
das ist halt ein Problem,
wie gesagt, in Anführungsstrichen. Sehe ich nicht ein.
Und auch diese Actions,
das ist halt einfach nur eine Config,
die sehr so simpel deine Sachen
beschreibt. Nicht mehr so, wie wenn du AWS-Services
nutzt, wo du dich halt wirklich einmauerst
im Amazon-Ecosystem, wo du halt
Zeug richtig scheiße.
Dieses Amazon-Lied, wo einer irgendwie alle Amazon-Produkte
in einem Lied, das muss ich mal in die Schleunze.
Das kriegst du in einem Lied unter? Das ist ein 10-Minuten-Song
oder was?
Nee, aber wenn du jetzt sowas wie
Terraform nutzt, wo du halt
verschiedene Anbieter wieder versuchst, da einen Hut zu bringen
unter eine API, wo du dann
ein bisschen agnostisch, auf welchem
Cloud-Provider du unterwegs bist, deine Sachen konfigurieren kannst,
dann bist du halt, wenn du ABS-Kunde
bist, richtig ließ an ABS.
Das sind ganze Projekte,
die Teams wochenlang beschäftigen,
den Service, den sie bereits bei Amazon hosten,
vielleicht auch mal zur Redundanz,
auch noch bei einem anderen Cloud-Anbieter zu hosten.
Das ist nicht trivial, wenn du dich da richtig einfindest.
Und sowas wie GitHub Actions,
dadurch, dass es halt nur so eine super simple Config ist,
die eigentlich bloß die Schritte beschreibt
und den Namen des Docker-Containers, auf dem das Ganze läuft,
das kannst du halt, die GitLab CI-Jammel,
die ist fast genauso aufgebaut.
Und auch andere Services. Selbst wenn du das selber
betreiben möchtest, es gibt,
abgesehen davon, dass es wahrscheinlich einen Nachmittag kostet.
Da gibt es ja bereits dieses Act, womit du
deine GitHub-Actions lokal ausführen kannst.
Deswegen sehe ich das nicht als Login an der Stelle.
Wie gesagt, du hast private Vipos
nur was anderes, weil du da halt wirklich den
Zugang auch ermöglichst. Aber das ist ja
ähnlich, was wir mit der Open-Source-Welt beteiligen.
Wenn du wirklich Privates haben möchtest, dann machst du dir einen
V-Server auf und dann machst du alles über SSH.
Und wenn du dann noch ein Web-Interface haben möchtest,
dann kannst du dir da unten. Oder machst du es komplett lokal.
Das ist komplett lokal.
Die Leute, die Git erfunden haben,
die benutzen es immer noch via E-Mail.
Ist ja auch voll in Ordnung.
Aber dann hier wird halt auch
die Übernahme von GitHub und NPM
über einen Kamm geschoren.
Obwohl NPM irgendwann nicht direkt von Microsoft,
sondern ich glaube GitHub ist innerhalb von Microsoft
noch recht...
Das war das nachher, oder?
Also NPM wurde von GitHub gekauft nachdem GitHub Microsoft...
Das gefühlt ja gerade eben erst passiert,
das ist ja erst ein paar Monate her.
Was ist Zeit?
Was ist Zeit, ja.
Das ist im zweiten Jahr der Pandemie.
Ich weiß nicht.
Ja, tatsächlich, das ist krass.
Nee, doch nicht ganz.
Doch, doch, klar.
Auf jeden Fall.
Naja, wir haben bald...
Naja, wir sind nicht im zweiten Jahr des Lockdowns.
Das heißt, ich bin noch nicht ganz im zweiten Jahr des Homeoffice.
Ich glaube, ab März war ich im Homeoffice.
Also mein Lockdown-Office ging am 16. März 2020 los.
Ah, okay.
Ich weiß nicht genau.
Das ist das bald Jahr her, dass ich hier sitze.
Krass.
Hier.
Literally here.
Schon krass.
So, äh,
ba, ba, ba, ba, ba.
Oder es wurde über einen Kamm geschoren.
Es wurde über einen Kamm geschoren, genau.
Gut, also man kann jetzt kritisieren, dass NPM
GitHub gehört und
das GitHub Microsoft gehört und dass
das auf der anderen Seite haben die einfach
ein großes Interesse. Achso, genau.
Microsoft hat sich halt so ein bisschen
auf die Fahne geschrieben, dass sie
dieses TypeScript, JavaScript
Ecosystem am Leben erhalten
und unterstützen wollen. Und jetzt könnte man sagen,
die own das.
Aber vorher war es halt
auch schon von anderen Leuten geowned.
Es ist jetzt nicht so, als ob es irgendwie Gemeingut
wäre, was sie sich angeeignet haben.
Aber TypeScript kommt doch aus
Microsoft heraus, oder? Genau, auf TypeScript
kommen wir auch noch genauer ein.
TypeScript ist
ein Microsoft-Projekt
definitiv. Das ist ja nicht so, als ob TypeScript
irgendwas davon Closed Source wäre, oder?
Also du bist natürlich lizenzfähig jemand anderem.
Das ist halt so Open-Source zum Zugucken.
Also quasi so wie Android.
Google droppt hin und wieder mal so ein paar Brocken über die Mauer.
Nee, ich weiß gar nicht, ob es so genau ist.
Ich möchte da jetzt auch gar keine Aussage treffen,
wie offen oder verschlossen TypeScript zu Contributions von außen ist.
Es ist halt immer so, dass du Projekte hast.
Es gibt Projekte, die sehr offen sind,
weil sie einfach eh bloß,
Und ich glaube, das ist dann häufig, weil sie von kleinen Teams in Privaten gemacht werden.
Die freuen sich dann, wenn jemand anderes mitmacht.
Aber wenn du eine Firma bist, die ein Projekt entwickelt und da irgendwie eine Roadmap hast und das Open Source machst,
dann hast du da einigermaßen, obwohl es Open Source ist, lässt du da nicht jeden alles mitmachen.
Bloß weil er sagt, hier, guck mal, ich habe mich mal drei Wochen hingesetzt und habe mal das hier von euch komplett neu designt und anders gemacht.
Das nimmst du dann natürlich nicht an, weil das ist dein eigenes Projekt.
Das machst du halt Open Source, damit es transparent ist
und damit Leute
schon was beisteuern können, aber
der Project Lead
ist halt schon in dem Team
und wenn du das anders machen willst,
dann machst du halt TypeScript
mit einem I oder so
anstatt mit einem Y.
TypeScript.
Aber nur mal kurz den Bogen
zu schlagen, weil ich es bei Swift gerade im Kopf habe.
Was ich gerade sagen wollte,
und sowas wie Swift gehört ja auch komplett Apple.
Ja,
es vereint halt beides so ein bisschen.
Also prinzipiell, Apple hat
die Sprache rausgehauen.
Apple entwickelt die Sprache grundsätzlich weiter.
Aber Apple hat sich halt auch sehr,
also man kann natürlich fragen,
wie das wirklich passiert, aber hat sich auf die Fahne geschrieben,
wir wollen nicht die
Core-Custodians der Sprache
sein, sondern aus dem
Core-Team gibt es explizit auch Leute, die nicht
bei Apple arbeiten. Und
der Evolution-Prozess ist offen.
Also jeder kann Proposals setzen,
jeder kann contributen, aber
natürlich hat Apple, wie du schon meintest, auch eine
Roadmap für Swift und Apple hat
Features, die in Swift landen wollen und auch wenn die
Entwicklung von Swift offen ist, gibt
es gewisse Sachen, die ein bisschen
gepusht werden, ein bisschen hart
von Apple gepusht werden.
Diese Result-Builder-Syntax,
ich weiß nicht, ob du die kennst, aber können wir vielleicht mit einer
anderen Folge machen,
wo halt nicht ganz klar ist,
warum das so eine Prio hat,
bis SwiftUI rauskam und das
extensiv genutzt hat. Und zu SwiftUI hat Apple
halt gar nichts gesagt, weil das wieder ein
Close-Ding war, was
halt erst für WDC hier als Überraschung
vorgestellt wurde. Da wollten sie
gar nichts sagen, typisch Apple
halt, dass sie sowas
zurückhalten, bis es raus ist.
Und dann war erst wirklich klar, warum
das eben für
Swift so relevant war,
das zu entwickeln. Also du kennst
von außen natürlich die Roadmap, die Apple da intern hat.
Das ist so das Problem,
das sieht man auch
bei den Leuten, die sich mit
WebRTC beschäftigen. Das ist zwar
irgendwie was Standardisiertes, aber
die
wichtigste Implementierung
ist die in Chrome und
das ist auch so ein Ding, da hat Google absolute
Finger drauf und da hast du keinen Einblick, wann
da mal, du kannst da Tickets aufmachen,
du kriegst den Code, wenn du den irgendwie mit
deren Tool runterlädst
und mit deren
eigenen internen Bildsystem baust,
kriegst du es irgendwie hin.
Das ist auch bloß nicht Gittes, weil das irgendwie aus dem Google
Monorepo runterladen musst?
Wusstest du das, wenn du das Google Monorepo
auscheckst? Also ich hab das auch
aus Hörensagen, soweit ich das verstanden hab.
Als Entwickler bei Google,
dann hast du quasi irgendwie
so ein Fingerprinting im Code mit drin.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das sowas ist wie Warnometer Whitespace
oder wahrscheinlich mehrere Sachen,
dass wenn du den Code irgendwo
verstreuen solltest, dass klar ist,
welcher Checkout das war, der abhanden gekommen ist.
Oh.
Oh, das kann ich mir.
wie funktioniert dann
Checksums in deren Repo?
Keine Ahnung.
So Monorepos
at Google Scales sind ja eh nochmal ein ganz anderes
Ding dieses Jahr.
Anyway, also zumindest,
Typescript ist halt wirklich,
das ist gehostet auf github.com
slash Microsoft slash Typescript
und ich habe mich noch nicht
damit beschäftigt, wie da das Contribution-Modell ist,
aber es ist natürlich ein Projekt von Microsoft.
Fertig. Es ist Open Source.
Du kannst Tickets aufmachen,
Du kannst den Code komplett runterladen.
Du kannst da Pull-Requests aufmachen.
Es gibt keine Garantie darüber,
dass die sich jemand anguckt oder dass die
angenommen werden.
Aber wenn die Möglichkeit besteht, dass die eben angenommen werden,
also generell so ein Contribution-Modell
ist, finde ich, schon mal echt was wert.
Ich kenne,
weil ich mich am ehesten auskenne,
die Parallelen zu Apple schlagen.
Apple macht ja auch schon
immer Open Source.
Seit Anbeginn der Firma, weil sie es halt lizenztechnisch
mussten, auf opensource.apple.com
findest du halt alle Sachen, die Apple
halt Open-Sourcen musste, aber das
sind halt nur, du kannst die Tauberlust runterladen
davon. Also da kannst du halt nichts
kontributen. Du kannst nur die Dinge einsehen, weil
sie die Open-Sourcen mussten.
Aber mit Swift haben sie da eben
auch auf GitHub gegangen und das war so ein Riesending,
weil, wow, das wird entwickelt
im Offenen. Du kannst Commits sehen,
du kannst History sehen. Die hat auch die
komplett vergangene History mit drin, also wahrscheinlich
nicht komplette, aber die hatten die
vergangene History mit drin. Das heißt, du kannst auch noch bevor
aus Open Source zurücksteigen und durch die History
gehen und du hast dann auch in der Zukunft
die Möglichkeit, Contributions zu machen,
Pull-Requests zu stellen, die gemerged werden
und das ist halt schon mal noch was ganz anderes
an Open Source, das auch öffentlich zu entwickeln
und die Möglichkeit für Contribution dem zu haben.
Genau, also
als Zusammenfassung
würde ich sagen, Open Source
ist ein Spektrum.
Klar, alles ist ein Spektrum.
Und da ist das eine Projekt
wahrscheinlich auf der offenen
Seite und das andere eher auf der geschlossenen
Also ich habe Open-Source-Projekte,
ganz kleine Libraries, wenn mir da einer
einen Pull-Request schickt,
nehme ich den sehr, sehr gerne an, wenn das
sinnvoll ist. Ich habe da auch keine
große Roadmap bei meinen Sachen, ehrlich gesagt.
Aber gut, okay.
Der erste Contributor, den du findest,
zu dem wird das Projekt direkt transferiert,
der ist jetzt der Maintainer. Glückwunsch.
Das habe ich noch nicht gemacht
tatsächlich. Das habe ich letztes Mal gemacht.
Für irgendeine Bullshit-Kleine-Library,
die ich vor, keine Ahnung, fünf Jahren geschrieben habe.
Einer hat eine
Show aufgeweisen, willst du machen?
Ich will das nicht mehr machen.
Ich hab keine Lust mehr.
Ach naja, das ist für mich so das bisschen Knobeln.
Also ich hab da, wie gesagt, die Sachen, die ich da habe,
das hab ich auch bloß zum Spaß gemacht.
Und wenn ich da ab und zu nochmal was dran mache, wenn ich
jemand forken will, bin ich auch nicht böse.
Vielleicht wäre ich doch ein bisschen enttäuscht.
Wer weiß, egal.
Jetzt könnten wir hier mal weiterlesen.
Microsoft's Mission is to turn every JavaScript
Developer into a Microsoft TypeScript
Money-Generating-Drone one way or another.
Okay, das ist eine harte Aussage.
Also, warte mal, die wollen.
Es geht ja mit darum, dass die
JavaScript-Entwickler in das TypeScript-Ecosystem
reinpressern, dass Leute halt quasi
mit TypeScript entwickeln
und sie damit irgendwie Geld machen.
Also, wenn das so ist, bin ich quasi diese,
wenn ich so eine Money-Generating-Drone,
weil ich TypeScript schreibe,
in VS Code und Geld damit generiere.
Wie generierst du denn Geld für Microsoft?
Gar nicht.
Okay, geht ja weiter.
Also, Act 1. Microsoft kills
JavaScript. Okay.
Microsoft may not be able to innovate on
products and they usually
fail miserably.
Das ist jetzt Quote, ne? Ich lese hier
diesen Hacker-Noon-Artikel,
den ich nicht geschrieben habe.
But it is shockingly
good at marketing, propaganda
and takeovers. Wahrscheinlich.
Also die Person hat echt eine gute Meinung schon mal zu Microsoft.
Ich meine, Microsoft hat auch viel Negativity verdient über die Jahre.
Wenn man mit der Prämisse schon anfängt,
dann weiß man halt klar, wo sie geht.
Definitiv nimmt dir hier kein Blatt von den Mund.
Aber es ist natürlich auch so, wenn du eine große Firma bist,
da laufen halt Sachen, da bist du kein großer Innovator mehr.
Dann machst du deine Innovations entweder,
indem du die Entwickler, die du hast, wenn du denen sagst,
macht, was ihr wollt und nicht
Feature after Feature auf dem Projekt,
auf dem ihr eh schon seit 10 Jahren arbeitet,
sondern macht irgendwas, tobt euch aus, dann kommt
vielleicht ab und zu mal aus so einer Bude mal eine Innovation raus
oder indem
du eine andere Bude kaufst, die eine Innovation hat
und die du dann zum Teil deiner Produktfamilie machst,
was halt große Firmen meistens machen.
Ich verstehe nicht, worauf der hier überhaupt eingehen möchte.
So wie ich das hier verstehe,
den Content hier,
sagt die Person, dass Microsoft JavaScript
getötet hat, indem sie TypeScript erfunden haben
und TypeScript populär ist.
Ja, hier stehen auch Sachen drin, die wirklich...
Aber das macht doch JavaScript nicht tot.
Also ich meine, schön, wenn niemand mehr
JavaScript nutzt, weil TypeScript einfach besser ist,
dann haben sie JavaScript getötet. Ja,
stimmt, aber doch nicht. Das ist
noch nicht... Also, das kann man dir noch nicht
zulassen. Das liest sich hier für mich
auch wie ein anderer Blogpost,
den ich von jemand anders gelesen habe, der
wo irgendwo mit drin stand,
ich hab mir übrigens TypeScript nicht so genau angeguckt,
weil ich es scheiße finde.
Hier, Understanding the Propaganda
steht hier. The JavaScript
Scale-Narrative is aimed mostly at the business decision makers,
positioning TypeScript as a reliable and robust choice
versus the bug-prone, unreliable vanilla JavaScript.
Over time, this will deprecate JavaScript
as a language in business environments.
It will become the new PHP.
Also mal abgesehen davon,
ich gehe fest davon aus,
meine Erfahrung ist jetzt nicht hier auf festen Zahlen basierend,
aber zumindest auch meine Erfahrung in meiner Firma
und von Leuten, von denen ich gelesen habe,
ist PHP um ein Faktor sonst was populärer
als JavaScript in Business Deployments, würde ich behaupten.
Ja, es wird wahrscheinlich...
Um ein Vielfaches.
Ich habe schon den Eindruck, dass Node.js gerade so das Java
der 2010er 2020 ist.
Aber okay, man versteht diesen Propagandaanspruch,
dass Microsoft hier versucht, über Marketing an POs gerichtet
und Produktmanager gerichtet, die zu pressure...
nicht zu pressuren, die dazu zu bewegen,
auf TypeScript zu setzen und die
würden dann die Entscheidung treffen, dass neue
Entwicklungen in TypeScript passieren und
sie machen JavaScript damit irrelevant.
Das ist die Aussage hier.
Das ist so die Aussage hier und dann steht hier noch
And so as not to offend
JavaScript developers too much, the TypeScript
is a superset of JavaScript
narrative was introduced,
which for obvious reasons is
naively
erroneous at best. TypeScript
does not
TypeScript does use
JavaScript Constructs, but
has a lot more in common
with C Sharp.
CIS. Sprachen jetzt nicht im Deutschen CIS.
Ach, CIS.
Spaß. Ich sag das immer wieder gerne.
Aber nee, okay, das ist so CIS.
Das musst du sagen. Stimmt das?
Ist TypeScript ein super CIS oder stimmt das nicht?
Also diese beiden Punkte, dass es irgendwie
Business-Leute und Decision-Makers ansprechen soll,
habe ich so noch nicht erlebt.
Ich bin eher...
Ich bin ja nicht die Kundschaft für das.
Ich habe eher gesehen, bei uns haben sich die Entwickler gewünscht,
dass wir bitte TypeScript machen dürfen.
Okay.
Und es wurde dann...
Weißt du, die Propaganda auch?
Es war dann eher auch, wir waren dann auch teilweise eher im
Rechtfertigungstrang, warum wir jetzt irgendwie
zwei Sprints darauf investiert haben,
unsere JavaScript-Codebase zu
vertypescripten. Und da haben wir gesagt,
wir sind ganz schön froh, dass wir es gemacht haben,
hätte ich gesagt. Und das sind die Ingenieure, die das
machen. Und dann die zweite Aussage,
TypeScript ist halt kein Superset von
JavaScript, sondern ist eher, hat viel
in Common mit C-Sharp, das ist einfach blatantly
Quatsch.
Weil TypeScript
führt einfach
auf der Run-Ebene, wenn du alles, was TypeScript
selber ausmachst, wegnimmst, bleibt
pures Vanilla-JavaScript übrig.
Also TypeScript ist Superset von JavaScript.
TypeScript ist JavaScript. Und was du hinzufügst,
sind einfach Typ-Deklarationen,
die du vorher halt in JavaScript
selber nicht hattest.
Und es ist,
wie sagt man auf Deutsch,
it's bending over backwards,
um das Typsystem, was JavaScript tatsächlich schon hat,
in irgendeiner Form auszudrücken, die den Compiler versteht.
Also das ist, muss ich sagen, die große Leistung.
Es hat ein ziemlich krasses Typsystem,
was es dir erlaubt, das auszudrücken,
was du mit JavaScript schon vorher ausdrücken konntest,
bloß auf eine Art und Weise,
dass du es mit einem Compiler statisch checken kannst.
Als jemand, der generell kein TypeScript schreibt,
weil das einfach nicht mein Stack ist,
was ist denn da der aktuelle Status Quo,
wenn du TypeScript-Code schreibst?
ich rede mal nicht vom Browser-Kontext,
weil da wird es wahrscheinlich sowieso zu JavaScript kompiliert,
aber wenn ich sage mal, irgendeine
Node-Anwendung, also irgendwas, was auf dem
Server oder auf deinem Rechner oder wo auch immer läuft,
direkt, wenn du sowas in TypeScript
baust, gibt es Möglichkeiten, ich glaube,
das war ja mit Dino der Ansatz, dass du TypeScript
direkt ausführst, oder wird das immer
auf JavaScript kompiliert? Was
Dino macht, ist,
dass du dem zwar sagen kannst,
hier friss einfach diese TypeScript-Datei,
das macht Node nicht, aber was Dino macht,
ist, dass du... Das Dino macht auch bloß inzwischen.
Das hat den Compiler eingebacken.
Ach so.
Macht, je nachdem, wie du es konfigurierst,
das dünnste Type-Checking möglich,
das möglich ist.
Manchmal strip das auch einfach weg.
Wenn du ihm sagst,
du musst es für mich nicht checken, führ es einfach aus.
Und dann wird das einfach...
Kannst du quasi als unsafe-Flag mitgeben?
Ja, ich weiß nicht genau, wie Dinos das macht,
aber da ist auch bloß V8 drin.
Das ist auch einfach.
Was so ein bisschen dann von dem Projekt,
von den Sachen abweicht,
sind dann so Projekte wie AssemblyScript.
AssemblyScript ist ein Dialekt von TypeScript,
wo du dann nicht Typen hast wie in JavaScript,
ein Number, sondern da hast du dann I32, I64, F32,
wie in Rust für Zahlen.
Und das ist dann was, was tatsächlich nicht kompatibel ist.
Es ist, sagen wir mal, zu 90 Prozent ähnlich,
aber es soll zum Schluss direkt nach WebAssembly kompilieren.
Das ist dann wirklich was anderes.
Und TypeScript hat ein paar Sachen gemacht,
die jetzt auch frowned upon sind.
dass sie Sprachkonstrukte hinzugefügt haben,
wie Enums und Namespaces,
die
Code erzeugen. Also da wird JavaScript,
du kannst in TypeScript einen Enum schreiben
und dann wird da, wenn das
kompiliert wird, wird ein Objekt
mit einem Lookup draus gemacht, dass du sagen kannst,
hier mein State.joint
hast du jetzt einen Enum.
Wenn es die mögliche Abbildung in JavaScript ist,
dann ist das halt so.
Sowas wird aber mittlerweile
mehr und mehr discouraged,
weil es tatsächlich nicht reines JavaScript
ist. Du schreibst dann TypeScript, was Code
erzeugt und eigentlich ist die Philosophie, das war,
wie gesagt, ein relativ altes Kompunkt.
Die Philosophie von TypeScript ist eigentlich,
dass es
genauso wie Flow einfach dir
Typechecking erlaubt, das halt
als Teil der Syntax macht, aber ansonsten der Code,
der rausfällt, ist das Gleiche, was du könntest, den gleichen
Code produzieren, indem du einfach hingehst und die ganze
TypeScript-Syntax wieder wegmachst und
die Typen rausnimmst und dann hast du genau
das, was der TypeScript-Compiler zum Schluss auch erzeugt.
Okay.
Das ist so der Ansatz.
Das heißt, es fällt so oder so JavaScript am Ende raus
und die Philosophie ist,
Goga geht noch drei Schritte weiter
und will eigentlich, dass es eins zu eins JavaScript
kompatibel bleibt.
Also ich bin kurz davor, wenn wir nicht bei uns in der Codebase
Exzessive Enums nutzen würden,
es gibt Linter,
die du einstellen kannst, wo du
Enums verbieten kannst.
Weil du kannst stattdessen auch
Unions mit String-Literalen benutzen.
Du sagst hier, dieser State
ist ein Typ, der kann diese drei String-Typ-Werte
annehmen und das reicht, das macht genau die gleiche
Funktionalität. Nach Inams sind auch was anderes, ich dachte,
das sind schon die Inams gewesen.
Du hast ein Inam, da steht drin,
die unterschiedlichen Felder und das bildet dann
auf 0, 1, 2, 3 oder auf irgendwelche Strings
ab und das erzeugt ein Objekt, das heißt
du kannst, wenn du einen Inam-Wert
bekommst, der dann 0 ist,
obwohl da, was weiß ich,
Default stand oder sowas,
kannst du dann das Inam nehmen, weil es ein Objekt ist
und dann erzeugt das irgendwie, ich könnte das mal
Play, das ist
jetzt auch was, was ich vielleicht ein bisschen
Kälte für die Aufnahme.
Play TypeScript.
Machen wir es mal so.
Wenn ich jetzt hier,
das ist
dieser Playground
und
das ist jetzt, was hier auf der anderen Seite
rauskommt.
In TypeScript gibt es den
Inam
Foo.
Ja, genau, deswegen ist es ja auch
da wird halt ein Scope erzeugt
und das ist halt hier, weil es nach
in einem alten Ortpunkt
da hast du jetzt hier
hast du jetzt
foo
und bar und
bars, ne, und dann kommt
da dieses Objekt bei raus, und dann
kannst du nämlich hinterher sagen
console.log
foo.bar
ne, dann wird dir zwei oder eins
gedruckt, ne, und
was es dir halt erlaubt ist, dass du
sagen kannst, von dem foo
gib mir mal das
FUBAR und dann kriegst du den, dann macht
er halt rückwärts den Lookup, sodass du weißt, dass da
BAR drin steht. Ah, verstehe.
Und das ist aber genau dasselbe, was du ausdrücken kannst,
indem du sagst, äh,
Type FU2 ist
gleich, äh, äh,
FU
oder
BAR, ne, das ist, das ist
besser.
Da kommt nämlich überhaupt nichts bei raus.
Das ist einfach bloß statisch.
Sind die namens ein neueres Feature von Timescript?
Nee, das ist wie gesagt ein altes Feature.
Es gab auch, innerhalb vom
TypeScript-Compiler wird ganz exzessiv
ein Feature namens Namespaces
verwendet. Das ist auch so ein richtig
ekliges Namespace-Konzept, was so
wie bei C ist, wo der Namespace
sich über mehrere Module erstrecken
kann. Und die haben
auch seltsame Side-Effects. Und diese
beiden Features
sind als Namespaces sollst du gar
nicht mehr verwenden.
und Inams, na gut, Inams werden halt noch
an vielen Stellen, das spricht sich noch nicht so rum,
dass Inams auch nicht so schön sind eigentlich.
Aber ansonsten ist es wirklich...
Zigerweise nutzen wir den Swift
Inams als Namespaces.
Zum Beispiel.
Genau, also
wie du ja siehst,
Inam ist ein Beispiel, was relativ
viel Code erzeugt. Da wird dir jedes Mal hier so ein
Lookup-Objekt erzeugt. Aber ansonsten benutzt
du es einfach nur anstatt von Statics
und da könntest du hier auch so
an dieser Stelle auch so ein bisschen
Text reinschreiben.
Da musst du aber, glaube ich,
wenn du das machst, dann kannst du...
Dann brauchen alle, okay.
Dann brauchst du offenbar alle.
Weil den Rest da nicht irgendwie standardmäßig ausfüllt.
So, dann kannst du das.
Aber da verstehe ich auch die Begründung, warum das eine frowned upon ist
und warum die Juden da sinnvoller sind.
Und da, äh,
batz,
lässt du mich das...
Ich hasse dieses automatische Dings vervollständigen.
So, und das ist,
da haben sie halt so am Anfang ein bisschen rumgedruckst,
weil halt so viel Code erzeugt wird, gibt's auch noch
const-enums
und das ist dann wieder
weg.
Und was macht der da jetzt?
Der ersetzt dann an jeder Stelle,
wo du es benutzt, das durch den String, den du hier
verwendest.
Da kannst du dann aber dieses Lookup hier wieder nicht mehr machen.
Okay, da gibt's Sinn.
So. Witzig.
Anyway.
Aber okay.
Nur mal zurückzufassen,
zusammenzufassen, TypeScript ist ein Super-Supp von
JavaScript.
Ja, genau. Also es ist Argument, die einfach Schwachsinn.
Genau. Und ich kann
verstehen, dass viele Leute, die
dass viele Leute Widerstand gegen
TypeScript haben und wenn du in ein Projekt kommst, wo du sagen,
wo jetzt die Hälfte, der eine Hälfte der Leute sagt,
wir machen jetzt TypeScript, ich find's geil und die
andere Hälfte sagt, JavaScript kannst du auch alles mit JavaScript
machen, ist doch das
pure Ding. Da brauchst du ja auch diesen Compiler
nicht. Wir haben teilweise Compile-Zeiten für unseren
TypeScript, die sind traurig.
Kann ich völlig verstehen, hab ich alles erlebt.
Auf jeden Fall, aber es ist halt, wenn du jemand bist
und es ist halt was für Leute, die von woanders
kommen, wenn du aus
C++ Java
kommst und dann JavaScript machen sollst,
wo irgendwie die alles
ausprobieren musst, was du machst.
Und dir alles zur Runtime um die Ohren fliegen kann, wo du
diese garantierten alle nicht hast.
Es ist ja auch ein geistiger Overhead.
Auf jeden Fall, du musst halt mehr Compiler spielen, wenn der Compiler
nicht existiert. Du schreibst tonnenweise Zeugs
für Sachen, die dir der Compiler abnehmen
kann. Das ist natürlich was, deswegen
sich Leute, das will ich nicht machen.
Deswegen wird JavaScript auch von allen Leuten
abgelehnt und irgendwie scheiße gefunden.
Obwohl JavaScript eine der
schnellsten Skriptsprachen ist, die es gibt.
Anyway, also das ist so
dieser
Contempt, den ich hier rauslese,
der absolut nicht
den ich absolut nicht teilen kann.
Jetzt kommt ja als nächstes
hier Proprietary Open Source.
Das
hatten wir schon besprochen.
Akt 2, Microsoft Acquires GitHub.
Da haben wir auch schon relativ viel drüber geredet.
Akt 3, Microsoft acquires NPM.
Naja, also sagen wir es so, dass NPM der Backbone der JavaScript-Community war, das war an und für sich schon das Problem, möchte ich behaupten.
Und nicht die Tatsache, dass es dann irgendwann von Microsoft gekauft wurde.
Ja, also ich meine, gut, wir haben in JavaScript ja auch diese klassischen Dependency-Hell-Probleme, die wir da halt über die Jahre aufgebaut haben und das wird halt nur exacerbated, also verschlimmert dadurch, dass wir halt, also ich sage mit wir meine ich jetzt hier weniger mich, weil ich NPM wie gesagt nicht nutze, aber generell die Dev-Community, auch wo die ganzen JavaScript-Entwickler,
die halt ihre Software so bauen, beziehungsweise ihre Bildsysteme so bauen, dass halt alles ständig von NPM gezogen wird.
Und damit hast du halt so eine feste Dependency auf diese Firma so ingrained in dieses Environment.
Du kannst ja was Kript, du kannst Node quasi gar nicht entwickeln, ohne eine Abhängigkeit auf NPM als Firma zu haben.
Also wer hier in diesem Artikel
NPM irgendwie lobt
und es schade findet, dass es von
Microsoft gekauft wurde, der kennt irgendwie, glaube ich,
die gesamte Geschichte nicht. Weil es gibt genauso gut
aus der Open-Source-Java-Skript-Szene
Leute, die gesagt haben, NPM ist scheiße.
Wir wollen es loswerden.
Ich glaube ja auf dem
JS-Kongress, weißt du noch vorher,
als wir auf Konferenzen gegangen sind?
Vorträge von Leuten, kann ich gerne
mal verlinken, die bei
NPM gearbeitet haben und
darüber rumgehatet haben, was das für eine Firma
ist und dass sie jetzt ihre eigenen
Package-Manager bauen und wie
NPM als Package-Manager
eigentlich die JavaScript-Community
quasi wie
Hostage genommen hatte,
weil es irgendwie nur dieses eine zentrale Ding
gab, für was, was aber eigentlich ja Open-Source
sollte ja eigentlich dezentral sein.
Ich meine, es wäre wahrscheinlich auch nicht so
problematisch geworden, wenn
nicht JavaScript als
Community sich da zuell entschieden hätte,
dass so exzessiv...
Die Community war halt...
schoben und gleichzeitig hat die Community
das halt exzessiv genutzt und sich somit
richtig gut verpackt. Genau, es war halt super convenient,
deswegen hat die Community, was ja eigentlich auch
nicht wirklich eine kohärente
Community ist, sondern
tonnenweise Entwickler, die entweder
wenig Zeit haben und Geld verdienen müssen,
oder die irgendwie lazy sind und sich nicht
interessieren. Oder Leute, die halt so proliferant
sind und kleine Packages schreiben für
jeglichen Scheiß. Genau. Das passt ja
alles wunderbar zusammen. Aber die Tatsache, dass da
halt so eine Firma dieses Ding hinstellt,
dieses NPM hostet und
eigentlich von Venture Capital finanziert ist
und Interesse daran hat, irgendwie
Geld zu verdienen, das haben sie halt auch
jahrelang alle hingenommen und jetzt
als NPM fast lief.
Es lief und du konntest es halt nutzen, ohne drüber
nachzudenken. Und wenn NPM mal down ist,
alle so, oh mein Gott, ich kann nichts mehr
bauen und Fefe macht sich drüber lustig und
alle anderen, die außen stehen,
ihr hängt an der Firma und alle, die halt
das genutzt haben, ohne zu merken, shit, wir hängen dran,
merken halt in dem Moment, oh shit,
wir hängen dran. Und dass das jetzt Microsoft
acquired hat,
ich muss sagen, also das ist natürlich
für Microsoft gut, weil es ist tatsächlich ein
zentrales Stück Infrastruktur, was
gemissmanaged war oder was
finanziell,
also allein dadurch, dass es in finanzieller
Schieflage war und dass es gekauft
werden konnte
und Microsoft hat einfach bloß daran
ein Interesse, dass es weiterläuft. Natürlich kann man
da jetzt noch, die genauen Motive kann ich
nicht genau bestimmen, aber wenn man
sich mit Leuten, ich habe ganz kurz mit Leuten
geredet, die bei Microsoft arbeiten
die haben halt gesagt, ja, wir haben GitHub gekauft, damit es weiterläuft
und wir lassen die einfach machen.
So ist es halt momentan.
Das ist so die bestmögliche Übernahme.
Gut, man kann natürlich im Detail nicht, was da sonst für Entscheidungen noch reinfließen.
Das Gelenk wird auch auf einem längeren Roadmap hin.
Das ist so ein bisschen ein Verschwörungsglauben.
Ich glaube, Microsoft kann diese Firma so als
Developer-Outreach-Programm
Das ist halt der gute Teil von Microsoft, auch für uns Außenstände.
Für Microsoft kann ich mir vorstellen,
würde es vollkommen ausreichen.
Und vielleicht ist es einfach das,
dass es gut für deren
Images ist. Die sind mittlerweile
bevor sie GitHub gekauft haben,
einer der größten
Nutzer von GitHub.
Ich möchte jetzt nicht behaupten, dass alles mögliche Open Source war,
aber es gab halt diese große Open Source,
dieses große Open Source
Umdenken in Microsoft, als der Nadella
da eingestiegen ist.
Und die haben gesagt, wenn wir es nicht
unbedingt IP machen müssen,
wenn wir es nicht unbedingt Closed Source machen müssen,
dann machen wir viele Sachen einfach so,
Open Source, geht doch.
Und als so eine Firma möchtest du
immer auch, dass Entwickler deine
Sachen nutzen. Du möchtest, dass du
Entwickler anheuern kannst, die sich mit deinem Zeug
auskennen und deswegen unterstützt du sowas.
Ich kann mir schon durchaus vorstellen, dass das
einer der Hauptbeweggründe von Microsoft
an dieser Stelle ist.
Nächster Punkt ist jetzt,
Microsoft pushes VS Code as the
go-to-and-only-Editor for TypeScript.
Wollen wir da wirklich
drauf eingehen, ganz ehrlich.
Krüsste Fragen.
Also gut, dass sie den als
go-to-editor pushen, verstehe ich, ist ja der eigene
Editor, der wahrscheinlich am besten Support
für TypeScript hat
und deswegen sicherlich auch von TypeScript-Seite
immer wieder empfohlen wird als der beste Editor,
weil er halt den besten Support hat.
Aber inwiefern dieses in Klammern
and-only-Editor, limitieren die da irgendwas?
Es ist halt
genau so ein internes Projekt, was
so Open Source zum Zugucken ist.
Ich kann jetzt hier mal ganz kurz lesen, was hier sein Punkt
tatsächlich ist. When I started coding,
I watched hundreds of tutorials, followed
courses and read many
coding books and continue
to do so. And 99 out of 100
times, you hear people
continuously advise VR's
code as the best of the best
editors on the planet.
It is very rare that someone
even mentions Vim or WebStorm.
Der Punkt ist da, dass
VS Code Telemetry beinhaltet und
das kann man natürlich scheiße finden,
finde ich auch nicht geil, wenn Software
die Nutzer sowas beinhaltet. Es gibt ja auch
diesen anderen Teil von Microsoft, der Werbung
in das OS von denen mit einbaut.
Auch nicht geil. Also auf der Ebene,
das ist kacke, aber ich sehe nicht,
wo sie pushen, dass das der einzige Editor ist.
Gut, er wird gepusht als der besten
Supportedste und ergibt auch Sinn,
wenn das aus demselben Hause kommt und Microsoft
macht die wahrscheinlich wieder Mist in Anführungsstrichen
hier, weil die da eben sehr viel Telemetry
mit eingebaut haben. Also Telemetry ist
mal eine Sache. Telemetry möchtest
du, du hast als Entwickler von Software,
die irgendwo läuft, ein Interesse daran,
wie Telemetry zu machen.
Das ist natürlich,
dass das vielleicht bei einer amerikanischen Firma,
die kulturell kein wirklich großes Privacy-Verständnis haben,
manchmal zu weit geht und die Telemetry machen,
wo dann Rückschlüsse über die Benutzer.
Du kannst sowas super easy,
also nicht easy,
das will ich hier gar nicht oversellen,
aber du kannst Telemetry so bauen,
wie du schon meinst,
dass sie halt gute Privacy beinhaltet,
dass du im ersten Schritt
willst natürlich keine Nutzerdaten sammeln.
Du willst wissen, im Idealfall,
welche Features deiner Software werden genutzt,
welche Features lohnen sich weiter zu supporten,
welche Features können rausfliegen, weil die eh keiner nutzt.
Das ist ja das, was wir eigentlich damit wollen, wenn wir so die Telemetrie haben.
Und seitdem es sowas wie
GDPR gibt,
haben halt diese Firmen
auch alle Projekte am Start gehabt,
wo sie sich hingesetzt haben und ihre Telemetrie durchgehen.
Erstens wird das nach Endtagen, muss es definitiv
gelöscht werden. Zweitens darf es bestimmte Werte
nicht mehr in Binnen halten.
Ja, aber solche Sachen willst du halt prinzipiell von Anfang an nicht sammeln
und die meisten machen das gar nicht.
Das stimmt, die meisten würden wahrscheinlich alle sammeln,
wenn es geht.
Die meisten Firmen da draußen, sage ich mal.
Aber was du halt auch machen kannst,
es hat Apple mal einen Talk zu WDC vor ein paar Jahren gehalten,
wie sie sowas mit sammeln.
Also Apple sammelt ja auch haufenweise Daten.
Die wollen ja auch nutzen,
auch solche Sachen haben, glaube ich, in dem Talk mit das Beispiel,
welche Emoji am meisten genutzt werden auf der Emoji-Tastatur,
weil das ist ein schönes kleines Beispiel,
damit sie global oder zumindest in deinem Kontext,
was auch immer dein Kontext ist, deine Region.
Also das darf theoretisch,
das haben die noch nicht gemacht, aber das darf theoretisch
populäre Emoji auch mit
deinen Reasons schon gepusht werden können,
bevor überhaupt deine Reasons sind.
Da fragt man sich dann immer, ist es dann populär,
weil das die Leute gerne benutzen wollen
oder weil sie es auf ihrer Startseite gesehen haben?
Ja, wahrscheinlich.
Das war nur ein Beispiel für den Talk,
das machen sie so nicht, aber das war nur ein Beispiel.
Aber Apple sammelt halt so oder so sehr viele
Ternalmöchig-Daten auch aus dem Betriebssystem.
Aber was sie halt zusätzlich machen, worum es in dem Talk ging,
war dieses Konzept der Differential Privacy,
dass sie halt die Daten nicht einfach sammeln,
sondern dass sie die Daten lokal randomisieren
und sammeln mit einem ganz kleinen Faktor
in die Richtung,
dass du halt mehr randomisierst
auf die richtige Seite,
also auf die Seite, wo es halt wirklich ist.
Und somit hast du,
wenn du das große ganze Bild anschaust,
immer noch Daten,
die halt in die richtige Richtung zeigen,
aber du könntest selbst wenn du die einzelnen Datenpunkte anschaust,
hast du keinerlei Ahnung,
ob dieser Datenpunkt so überhaupt der Realität
auf dem Device entsprach oder nicht
und kannst, selbst wenn du möchtest, nicht mal
Rückschlüsse auf Nutzer führen. Selbst wenn du die Daten
hättest, die sie ja angeblich
auch nicht sammeln, nutzerspezifische
Daten, könntest du keine Rückschlüsse führen,
weil jeder einzelne Datenpunkt Müll
ist, aber das große ganze Bild halt immer
noch aussahkräftig ist. Und das fand ich einen super
interessanten Ansatz. Und so kann man das halt auch machen.
Also LamyTree ist nicht böse per se.
Wir müssten das ja auch irgendwo nutzen. Ich weiß, dass wir es auf Arbeit
genauso nutzen, weil wir halt in teilweise
super komplexen Applikationen...
Du brauchst es halt, um deinen Service auch irgendwie
qualitativ betreiben zu können. Du kannst nicht einfach
blind in alle Richtungen weiterentwickeln,
weil du halt dann scheiß komplexe Projekte hast,
die deine Kunden eh nicht mehr nutzen wollen, weil sie halt viel zu
komplex sind. Genau, und irgendwann kommen dir deine
Kunden und sagen,
hier das und das, ich bin mit deinem Produkt
unzufrieden, warum verbesserten ihr das nicht?
Und dann sagst du nur, ich wusste gar nicht, dass das bei dir
kaputt ist. Woher soll ich das wissen?
Oder du machst das, aber dann ist der eine laute
Kunde, der diese Meinung hat, halt auch
alleine mit seiner Meinung gewesen.
So, also das ist jetzt das.
Gut, okay, die haben halt ein Produkt gebaut, das ist
VS Code, die haben es halt, ich würde
nicht sagen, dass sie es als den Besten
gepusht haben, aber das ist halt das Team, was
TypeScript macht und das Team, das VS Code macht, die
arbeiten halt Hand in Hand. Das Ding ist selber in VS Code
gebaut. Wenn sie eine IDE für ihre
eigene Sprache bauen, dann bauen sie
das halt nicht für alle IDEs, sondern dann bauen sie
das halt für ihre eigene. Mein Gott,
dafür ist es halt Visual Studio.
Das würde wahrscheinlich auch, also ich, so wie ich, wenn ich
schon derjenige hier Wim und WebStorm
als Alternativen anbringe, es gibt ja sicherlich
auch gerade bei WebStorm,
JetPans ist ja sehr hinterher,
guten Support für sowas in ihre
IDEs einzubauen. JetBrains ist auch eine
Firma, die kein, das ist, JetBrains ist
nicht mehr Open Source, ne?
Das WebStorm ist,
oder? Nee, jetzt ich wüsste.
Das ist auch nicht Open Source. Vim
ist ein Editor und keine IDE.
Da musst du dir von anderen Leuten,
da gibt es diese ganzen Sachen. Und hier muss ich
echt mal eine Lanze für VS Code brechen,
VS Code waren diejenigen, die dieses Language
Server Protokoll Konzept überhaupt erst
losgetreten haben. Und das ist was, was ein
Mehrwert für alle IDEs
bringt, weil vorher hat jeder IDE
ihre eigenen Sprachanalyse
von vorne. Du hast ja, ich weiß, dass ich
jahrelang keine IDEs nutzen wollte,
weil das quasi das Gefühl, du kannst den Code
nur mit diesem
verheißenen
Programm schreiben. Du bist für mich der
Vim-User nach vorne. Ich war irgendwann geflasht,
als ich gesehen habe, man kann einfach einen Texteditor
nehmen, Vim, und dann schreibt man
Quelltext und dann nimmt man ein anderes Programm
und steckt es da rein, das ist dann der Compiler
und dann kommt da was raus oder man führt es einfach aus.
Ich muss nicht dieses komische
Eclipse nutzen, was ich mir in der Uni
wo ich mir gedacht habe, und ich weiß
heute noch nicht, wie ich Java bauen würde, wenn ich
nicht... Du kannst einfach Java auf der Commandline draufschauen.
Ja, ja, aber zumindest
so, und
selbst da war es halt so, wenn du C++
bauen wolltest, dann hast du halt Visual Studio
genommen, das ist halt so ein Ding, da ist Compiler und
Editor nicht wirklich voneinander zu trennen,
das ist ja vielleicht auch sinnvoll, oder
ich glaube, bei Visual Studio benutzen sie sogar
bei dem alten
bei dem richtigen Visual Studio
benutzen sie halt den Visual Studio Compiler,
um dein Ding zu bauen,
aber um die ganzen Textanalysen auf
deinem C++-Code zu machen, um dir
zum Beispiel herauszufinden, wenn du
auf der Klasse klickst, wo die implementiert ist,
benutzen sie einen anderen Compiler,
der überhaupt nichts damit zu tun hat.
Und so machen das, das ist ja quasi die
große Leistung von so Firmen wie
JetBrains, die
C-Line und WebStorm und
RubyMine und wie es alles andere heißt,
bauen die einen Editor
und quasi für jede Sprache,
selbst für Ruby und JavaScript,
einen Compiler. Also der Compiler,
das Ding, was
in WebStorm dafür sorgt, dass das
irgendwelche statischen Aussagen über dein JavaScript
treffen kann, ist halt ein komplexes Ding,
was eigentlich auch fast ein Compiler ist.
Und was hat nur VS Code gemacht?
Die haben das gleiche nochmal gemacht, bloß dass
sie halt... Die hätten auch den JetPit-Ansatz
machen können, hätten das für VS Code
spezifisch machen können. Ja, aber sie haben sich halt gedacht,
der ist aber bescheuert, wir bauen auch gleichzeitig
dieses Ding, was irgendwie statische Analyse
auf JavaScript macht, nämlich
TypeScripting, TypeScript Compiler.
Und was haben sie gemacht? Da haben sie halt aus dem TypeScript
Compiler so eine Art kleinen Server
Dings gemacht und die
füttern halt Informationen über den Code in den
TypeScript Compiler rein und der spricht halt mit diesem
Language Server Protokoll mit dem Editor
und alles was der Editor,
was VS Code über deinen TypeScript Code
weiß, weiß es vom TypeScript Compiler, der
quasi die ganze Zeit im VS Code mitläuft.
Und dadurch, dass er den Protokoll standardisiert
haben, haben sie gesagt, naja, dieses
Language-Server-Protokoll, das geht jetzt
hier in VS Code, das kannst du auch gerne
für eure anderen
Sprachen machen, das macht quasi
Rust-Analyzer oder was war
es vorher, Racer oder dieses andere
Rust-Plugin, was es vorher gab,
das hat es ermöglicht, dass VS Code mit
diesem Ding jetzt eine IDE für
alle möglichen Sprachen ist, wo einer sich hinsetzt und
so ein Language-Server-Protokoll braucht.
Und das Language-Server-Protokoll
wird auch von anderen IDEs
mittlerweile übernommen, jetzt in
In JetBrains IDEs kannst du jetzt auch Rust Analyzer oder diese Language Server Protokollgeschichten benutzen. Und das ist doch ein riesen Win für jeden, der eine Programmiersprache oder eine IDE baut. Du musst nicht mehr von vorne anfangen und dieses ganzen smarte Zeugs von vorne machen, sondern du sagst einfach, naja, da gibt es einen Compiler, den kannst du Sachen über den Code fragen und das stelle ich hier in meinem Editor dar.
Ja, wie gesagt, das ist ein absoluter Geniestreich gewesen, das so zu machen, weil nicht nur hast du was Tolles für die Allgemeinheit geschaffen, das muss ja nicht mal deine primäre Motivation gewesen sein, aber gleichzeitig hat das halt das unglaublich populärer gemacht, das Language-Tower-Protokoll, dadurch, dass alle das selber gebaut haben für ihre Tools dann, hat VS Code halt plötzlich die Komponibilität für alles gehabt, ohne dass Microsoft es hinsetzen musste.
Super praktisch für Microsoft.
Auf jeden Fall. Also das ist schon clever gewesen.
Aber man hat halt auch
ohne VS Code einen Mehrwert davon.
Das ist doch was Tolles. Definitiv.
Und ja, jetzt geht es hier weiter.
Microsoft Propaganda Machine is very efficient.
Das stimmt ja.
Das kann man ja unterschreiben.
Das Puschen von denen
und die Art und Weise, wie die das pushen,
ist effizient, weil sie ja anscheinend
sehr viel Erfolg damit haben.
Es ist halt Developer Advocacy.
Und ihre Produkte sind halt sehr attraktiv
für einen Großteil der Entwickler-Kompetenz.
Ja, aber die sind ja nicht nur attraktiv,
weil Microsoft Leute schmiert im Hinterzimmer oder so,
sondern weil sie halt die Sachen so bauen.
Also ich will jetzt hier nicht,
wie so ein Microsoft-Fanboy klingen,
aber sie bauen die Sachen ja so,
dass du sie nutzen willst,
weil die Sachen gut sind.
Die Sachen sind nicht geschlossen,
die Sachen sind nicht,
die schieben dich nicht,
du gehst hier keinen Deal mit dem Teufel ein,
sondern du nutzt die Sachen,
weil sie deine Probleme sehr effizient lösen,
sehr gut nutzbar sind.
Und du musst sie auch nicht unbedingt benutzen.
Du kannst hier VS Code-ium benutzen,
was quasi das Chromium für VS Code ist.
Du siehst hier, ich habe zufällig beide installiert.
Dann hast du VS Code,
ohne dass Microsoft über
die Bugs, die bei dir ausgelöst werden, informiert werden.
Gut, dann ist
die Telemetry da nicht mehr drin. Du kannst
das Language Server Protokoll nicht für
TypeScript, sondern für Rust oder
Swift verwenden.
Und hast quasi
das, was Microsoft hier an Open Source
beigetragen hat. Du kannst jetzt super Open Source
das einfach benutzen, ohne dass du irgendwas zurückgeben
musst oder ohne, dass du ausbenutzt oder gezwungen
musst. Das ist ein Win-Win auf beiden Seiten.
Wie gerade mit dem Language Server-Protokoll.
Microsoft schafft es, die Sachen so zu bauen, dass die Leute nutzen
wollen. Macht Microsoft glücklich, weil die Leute
Microsoft-Sachen nutzen, aber gleichzeitig hat
auch die Community was davon. Also ich sehe
hier nicht, wie Microsoft uns zu Hostage nimmt.
Aber es gibt noch einen Akt.
Es gibt noch einen Akt, ja. Und jetzt ist
nämlich der, also wofür steht dieses
Triple-E?
Was? Dieses
EEE, was im Chat
erwähnt wurde zu dem Thema,
das war hier vor meinen Grillfotos,
EEE steht für Embrace,
Extend, Extinguish.
Der erste Teil ist quasi,
wir umarmen euch und dann
tragen wir dazu bei
und dann wird das irgendwann alles abgeschaltet,
weil es ja Konkurrenz...
Aber es trifft das hier zu,
weil das würde dann quasi heißen,
naja, es gibt bald kein
JavaScript mehr, es gibt nur noch TypeScript.
Das ist tatsächlich...
Dass man halt Microsoft...
wir kennen natürlich nicht mehr, das Langzeitplan
und wenn die hier diesen
Embraise Extended Extinguish Flow fahren,
im Idealfall
würden wir ja nicht sehen,
wenn wir in Schritt 1 oder 2 sind,
weil da die Welt so heile aussieht
und danach kommt der böse Schritt, ohne dass wir es merken.
Ja, was jetzt passieren kann,
ist, dass Microsoft sagt, naja, also
TypeScript, das hat sich für uns nicht gelohnt,
wir feuern da jetzt alle und das machen wir
das jetzt halt aus, dann ist es halt.
Ja, aber dann ist TypeScript halt gestorben.
Aber dann sagst du halt, wir machen jetzt TypeScript
dann hast du es geforkt und dann wird sich
eine Community drumherum formen und dann
machen das Leute weiter. Solange es nicht
lizenztechnisch verboten ist, wovon ich ausgebe.
Das ist eine gute Frage. Unter welcher Lizenz steht
Microsoft, äh, unter welcher Lizenz
steht TypeScript?
Das kann man ja auf GitHub, Microsoft
TypeScript nachgucken.
Die haben ja dieses schöne Feature,
das sind hier einfach die Lizenzanzeigen,
das ist Apache 2 Lizenz.
Das ist nicht ganz MIT,
aber so,
es ist offen genug.
Also das kannst du auf jeden Fall forken und dein eigenes
Tipp-Skript draus machen. Genau.
Also was wären denn
andere anders, den Microsoft fahren können?
Was jetzt ja die Aussage
ist, dass sie irgendwie
JavaScript totmachen, dass es nur noch
TypeScript gibt, weil irgendwie alles nur noch in TypeScript
gebaut ist und es kaum noch mit einer JavaScript gibt.
Selbst wenn es so wäre,
TypeScript ist ja, wie wir gerade festgestellt haben,
kein geschlossenes Projekt. Also es würde uns ja nicht
wehtun,
TypeScript statt JavaScript zu nutzen,
auch wenn unter der Annahme,
dass TypeScript was anderes als JavaScript ist.
Aber das würde
ja nicht, also
ich sehe hier noch nicht den
Vektor, wo Microsoft die Möglichkeit hätte,
wenn sie alles in der Hand haben, wenn die
ganze Welt jetzt, wenn wirklich alle Entwickler nur noch
TypeScript schreiben und wir es Code nutzen.
Was müsste Microsoft tun,
um das,
also hätten sie ja
quasi. Also was
jetzt, also JavaScript
wird ja immer noch nicht von TypeScript irgendwie
gesteuert oder unter Druck gesetzt.
ist, TypeScript läuft
quasi mit dem, was sie machen, dem, was
JavaScript macht, hinterher. Bei ein paar
Sachen haben sie
zähneknirschen was vorgemacht
und dann ist es meistens
nicht gut angekommen. Es sind sich
Decorators, die TypeScript irgendwie
die ganze Zeit hinter einem Fleck anwarnen
und mittlerweile in JavaScript existieren
und anders funktionieren. Das war keine
gute Idee. Aber das war die Angular-Community,
die zu googeln gehören und das unbedingt haben wollten.
Ist Angular
Klar, Angular ist sogar tot.
Killed bei google.com.
War nicht ganz oben Angular?
AngularJS. Getting unplugged in 10 months.
Tot im Dezember 2021.
Ist AngularJS das alte
oder das neuere Angular?
Ich bin immer verwirrt.
Keine Ahnung.
Ich meine, diese Sachen. Angular gehört Google.
React gehört Facebook.
Also alles.
Microsoft könnte halt da hergehen und sagen,
wir haben mal drüber nachgedacht,
das TypeScript zu JavaScript kompiliert ist,
vielleicht doch nicht so optimal. Wir haben hier jetzt eine eigene
TypeScript Runtime geschrieben
und wir migrieren TypeScript jetzt darauf,
dass es nur noch das nutzt. Genau, dann hast
du sowas wie Dart. Das können
sie theoretisch tun. Ich meine, dadurch, dass
das TypeScript halt aktuell,
wie du ja schon sagst, relativ daran hängt,
möglichst JavaScript kompatibel zu bleiben
und sogar sich von Features verabschiedet, weil
die zu unschönem JavaScript führen,
beziehungsweise nicht zu idiomatischem JavaScript.
Weil es halt auch so Aussagen wie die hier gibt, dass es heißt,
ihr mit eurem TypeScript, ich mache
JavaScript, das ist the real deal quasi.
Ja, aber das sagt man doch auch nur,
weil man dann halt, also ich meine,
ich habe auch so dieses Gefühl,
eine Abstraktionsschicht rauszuschneiden, ist so
ein sauberes Ding.
Das fühlt sich an, als ob man so zu den Wurzeln
geht, man schafft Komplexität ab.
Das ist wie so ein Pull-Request, der
100.000 Zeilen löscht und keine
hinzufügt. Das fühlt sich einfach gut an,
weil es Dinge rauszieht,
die da anscheinend nicht sein müssen. Also ich habe den Eindruck,
dass es definitiv auch eine sauberere
Sache ist, als
Beispiel CoffeeScript, weil CoffeeScript hat
wirklich auch Code erzeugt und Sachen gemacht,
die vorher, also
du siehst ja dieses schöne Beispiel auf CoffeeScript.org
für
diese Zeile links CoffeeScript
wird recht so viel JavaScript-Code
erzeugt, das ist was, was du
was wirklich, ja, guck dir das
da an, das da, für das da
dann bloß damit du so eine komische
Python-eske, wie heißt das?
List Comprehension hast du
das ist was, dass
wenn TypeScript sowas machen würde, dann würde ich
Aussage verstehen, aber momentan
ist es eigentlich so, dass du einen relativ naiven Parzer
für TypeScript machen kannst und
der quasi einfach einmal
alles frisst, ohne wirklich genau zu verstehen,
ob es kompiliert oder nicht und dann nur
einen Teil der Syntax wieder ausspuckt und dann hast du quasi
dein Projekt von TypeScript befreit,
ohne dass du... Okay, man könnte ja
davon ausgehen, dass Microsoft
versucht, dass es aktuell noch in der Phase
sind, in der Embrace-Phase,
wirklich viele Leute in TypeScript reinzuziehen,
von TypeScript abhängig zu machen und
dann langsam versucht, dass halt
die Timescript von JavaScript zu entkoppeln.
Aber die sind halt
dadurch, dass das beides so offen ist
und dadurch, dass du halt prinzipiell die Möglichkeit
hättest, also die müssten eine sehr, sehr lange
Extend-Phase fahren,
bevor die Extend-Gestritte...
Was sie halt bei JavaScript nicht haben,
ist eine eigene Runtime.
Ihr Browser ist Chrome,
mit Edge.
Das, worauf
viele Services, die in JavaScript geschrieben sind,
laufen, ist Node. Das hat eine eigene
Foundation. Node nutzt auch nur V8, oder?
Du kannst Node gar nicht anders nutzen, oder?
Node läuft nur mit V8.
Es gibt irgendwie noch Forks
oder Alternativen von Node, die dann
die JavaScript-Engine von Firefox verwendet haben,
aber die sind, glaube ich, nie so richtig erfolgreich gewesen.
Dementsprechend
Microsoft hat ihre eigene JavaScript-
Die hatten ja ihre eigene JavaScript-Runtime
mit der Chakra-Engine, die in dem
Edge-Edge liefen.
Davon gab es
einen Node-Fork, der quasi
Node.js bloß nicht mit V8, sondern mit Chakra war.
Aber das haben sie ja selber alles weggeschmissen und haben gesagt,
nee, das brauchen wir jetzt nicht mehr entwickeln, das machen wir nicht mehr einfach Chrome.
Okay.
Und insofern...
Das ist das viel größere Monopol.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, da ist Chrome ja eher ein größeres Problem als Microsoft.
Da könnte man nochmal quasi den gleichen Blogpost nochmal aus der Perspektive,
was hat eigentlich Google mit dem Web gemacht, angucken.
Da haben wir schon ein paar Mal drüber gesprochen.
Mittlerweile ist eigentlich alles, was ein Webstandard ist,
ist irgendwie aus dem Hause Google gekommen.
Das ist eigentlich,
empfinde ich das als höhere Problem.
Also ich würde sagen,
nach diesem fünften Punkt,
dass man hier irgendwie Open-Source-Libraries
haben, irgendwie ein Business-Modell
und es gibt irgendwie Paid-Versionen davon.
Du, da würde ich gar nicht.
Ja, aber er sagt ja,
das ist hier quasi just a matter of time.
This is simply inevitable.
Natürlich war es,
oder es ist ja schon länger passiert,
dass Leute mit Software Geld verdienen wollen,
das ist ja nichts Neues, und
dass man halt auch versucht, mit
Libraries, die man halt anbietet,
in andere Softwares einzubauen, dass man damit versucht,
Geld zu verdienen, ist ja auch nichts Neues,
und dass du halt auch
Sachen, mit denen du Geld verdienst,
Open Source entwickeln kannst, ist ja auch nichts Neues,
und ich meine, dass das
mehr passiert, das ist wahrscheinlich jetzt das Ding,
woran sich die Person hier aufregt,
dass es halt populärer wird,
dass du solche
Freemium Open Source Libraries hast,
die halt, dass sie so ein Premium-Feature
mit haben, so ein Premium-Feature-Set,
was du halt dann irgendwie lizenztechnisch erwerben musst
und nur dann kannst du das nutzen.
Das ist übrigens ein Post, der auf Hacker nun gepostet wurde
und du kannst ihm hier Geld irgendwie zustecken
dafür, dass du das gelesen hast.
Das ist das auch so.
Das ist ja in Ordnung.
Das ist ja Zeit reingesteckt, das zu schreiben.
Aber ich meine, genauso ist es halt,
wenn du was programmierst,
da steckst du auch Zeit und Hirnschmalz rein
und es ist schön, wenn Sachen
Open Source sind oder Sachen free sind.
Natürlich betrifft das nicht alles.
Aber nicht jeder kann es sich leisten,
Software zu verschenken.
Ja, und andere wollen
mit ihren Firmen damit Geld verdienen.
Das ist ja nicht von Grund auf böse.
Das ist ja völlig legitim. Und wenn du
eine Möglichkeit hast, sowas zu monetarisieren,
die nicht scheiße ist, also im Sinne von
du verkaufst Nutzerdaten oder versteckst deine
Monetarisierung oder was weiß ich, dann finde ich
das auch völlig, also solange du Leute
nicht, also wie gesagt, solange du es nicht scheiße machst,
niemanden abzockst, niemanden verarscht oder sonst was
macht, ist das absolut
unterstützenswert, davon leben zu wollen.
Und davon leben zu wollen
beinhaltet jetzt auch, dass deine Firma sehr
viel Geld damit verdient, finde ich auch okay.
Dann hast du halt ein Businessmodell, was super
funktioniert. Je nachdem, was dein
Businessmodell ist, musst du halt auch eine gewisse
Art von Machtpolitik betreiben.
Wahrscheinlich, wenn du jetzt,
Microsoft hat wahrscheinlich,
die verdienen wahrscheinlich nicht mehr ganz so viel Geld
mit Windows-Lizenzen wie früher,
aber die haben eine große
Interesse daran, dass die Leute zu ihrer Azure-Plattform
ziehen. Na klar. Dann ist es natürlich praktisch, wenn
die Leute alle das Zeugs
entwickeln und benutzen wollen und können,
was auf deiner Plattform super läuft.
Auf jeden Fall. Ich meine, auch wenn du Azure nutzt, bist du genauso
wie bei AWS ziemlich eingesperrt.
Das ist bei Google nicht anders, bei Google Cloud
Plattform oder anderswo.
Es gibt überhaupt noch andere neben den drei großen.
Es gibt irgendwie Apple Cloud Plattformen, wo du was hosten
kannst, aber du darfst dann alles nur in Swift schreiben.
Apple nutzt auch AWS
für die iCloud.
Bzw. teilweise Azure, teilweise AWS.
Aber abgesehen davon,
ach, hier ist es halt nicht, wo ich hinwollte.
Also ich möchte behaupten,
diesen Punkt hier, diesen Blogpost haben wir
debunked.
Also ich zumindest
musste einiges Mal chackeln, als ich mir das
das erste Mal durchgelesen habe.
Und habe mir gedacht, nee, warte mal,
da gibt es schlimmere Beispiele.
Also da ist, wie gesagt, Amazon ein schlimmeres Beispiel.
Aber auch wenn du weißt,
schlimmere gibt, heißt das ja nicht, dass das valide sein muss.
Das stimmt.
Es gibt immer schlimmere Probleme auf der Welt,
aber ich gebe dir recht.
Ich glaube nicht, dass Microsoft
JavaScript umbringt.
Sie könnten darauf ausseiten,
sie könnten langfristig das Ziel haben,
aber einerseits sehe ich es noch nicht,
was man natürlich nicht heißen muss,
und andererseits sehe ich nicht,
wie sie die Möglichkeit dazu haben sollten,
ohne dass die Community,
also wenn sie ganz langsam die Community als Frosch
im heißen Wasser, im warmen Wasser
langsam die Temperatur hochdrehen,
es könnte sein, dass die Community langfristig
davon mitkriegt, dass Microsoft Mist macht.
Aber das sehe ich hier nicht passieren.
Komplett jenseits davon ist das eh
nicht mein Stack. Also habe ich damit gar nichts.
Ja, aber die haben auch kein großes Interesse daran,
das kaputt zu machen.
Das hat keinen Mehrwert. Ich sehe den Mehrwert nicht.
Du machst es zumindest nicht auf diese Art und Weise.
Wenn du Einfluss auf sowas wie eine Programmiersprache
oder auf so ein Ökosystem nehmen möchtest, dann machst
du das, indem du in diese Standardisierungsgremien
reingehst. Und das machen sie ja tatsächlich.
Es gibt dieses TC39, was quasi
das Standardisierungsgremium von ECMAScript
ist. Und da sitzen Microsoft
Mitarbeiter mit drin und reden drüber,
was jetzt
cooles Neues, was sie sich jetzt cooles Neues für
JavaScript ausdenken und alle sagen, ja,
das will ich haben. Und
dann gab es Diskussionen, saß ich
mit dem Raum vor ein paar Jahren bei JavaScript-Konferenzen,
wo dann gefragt wurde, wollen wir nicht
einfach endlich mal, jetzt ist ja TypeScript, ist ja da,
TypeScript ist geil, wollen wir nicht einfach mal
TypeScript Teil vom ECMAScript-Standard machen,
dass irgendwie diese Typen, die jetzt quasi
wohl bewährt sind und die gut zu
JavaScript passen, einfach
als Teil von ECMAScript
Dann wird die Syntax quasi heilig gesprochen und dann ist es offiziell, dass das Teil von JavaScript ist. So wie Type Annotations ja auch schon Teil von Python oder von Ruby zu einem gewissen Grad sind. Das trägt nicht wirklich zum Ausführen bei, aber du hast irgendwie was, was du statisch validieren kannst.
Weil Typen halt praktisch sind.
Ach.
Und da war die einhellige Aussage auch, die eindeutige Aussage auch von dem, ich habe den Namen vergessen, das ist glaube ich sogar ein deutscher, der heißt glaube ich Matthias irgendwas, da war auch glaube ich die Aussage von dem damals zugegebenermaßen vor drei Jahren, nee, da haben wir eigentlich kein großes Interesse dran.
Weil du dann, weil Microsoft selber an dieser Stelle ja dann quasi, gut, dann hätten sie die Hoheit an TypeScript abgegeben, so ist es momentan deren eigenes Ding, die können damit machen, was sie wollen und das wäre dann wahrscheinlich auch innovationsmäßig ein bisschen langsamer geworden, keine Ahnung.
Das wäre tatsächlich, ich hätte das geil gefunden.
Sagst du, pass auf, TypeScript gibt's nicht mehr, das ist jetzt alles JavaScript.
Und dann hättest du diese ganzen Diskussionen über, wie haben Union-Typen und Mapped-Types in TypeScript sich zu verhalten, wird dann einmal von dem TC39-Gremium beschrieben.
Da hast du natürlich, kommt dazu, dass du irgendwie eine komplette andere Komplexität auf diese Sprache oben draufsetzt.
die Leute, die sich mit dem JavaScript gestalten,
die beschäftigen sich mit anderen Sachen,
als mit welches Typsystem kommt da noch oben drüber,
womit man diese Sachen zufällig auch ausdrücken kann,
aber das irgendwie auch eine komplett neue Semantik hinzuwügt.
Das würde die Komplexität komplett sprengen für die wahrscheinlichsten.
Nein, sprengen nicht, aber du musst halt auch einsehen,
dass Sprachen sich irgendwie ein bisschen weiterentwickeln.
Und wenn du halt eine Sprache hast, die fast statisch ist,
aber ich sage nicht, dass JavaScript sich nicht weiterentwickelt,
JavaScript entwickelt sich rasend schnell weiter.
Aber wenn du sagen würdest, dass die Sprache sich nicht weiterentwickelt,
um den Leuten gerecht zu werden, die die Sprache einmal gelernt haben
und dann nie wieder, dann hättest du eine Sprache,
die nach fünf Jahren komplett outdated ist und in der Vergangenheit festhängt.
Aber Sprachen haben ja alle eine komplett andere Art und Weise,
sich zu organisieren.
Also TypeScript, Microsoft hat eine Kontrolle darüber,
was TypeScript macht, aber was zum Schluss bei rauskommt,
ist einfach wieder JavaScript.
Und die Kontrolle darüber, wie dieses JavaScript dann,
was das dann wirklich kann, hat Microsoft nicht,
die Runtimes nicht mehr zur Verfügung stehen.
Die Kontrolle hat Google,
also die Kontrolle hat nicht Google,
die Kontrolle hat schon noch das TC39
und die unterhalten sich dann darüber.
Google ist die E-Sebene drunter quasi.
Aber
Google ist insofern schon noch in gewisser
Weise ein Gatekeeper für
diese Sachen, bloß weil
die TC39 sich
ein Feature beschreibt und wünscht
und die Community dafür ist,
dass es jetzt Private Properties
in JavaScript gibt, heißt das nicht,
dass Google verpflichtet ist, in ihrer
JavaScript-Engine das zu implementieren.
Ja, stimmt.
Und auf der anderen Seite, wenn
Google möchte, dass es ein bestimmtes neues Feature
in JavaScript gibt, dann bauen sie es halt
und dann gibt es bereits eine Implementierung
und dann schlagen sie es der TC39 vor und dann geht es
einfacher, das zu standardisieren, weil es bereits eine Implementierung
gibt. Muss natürlich, wenn du
einen neuen Standards hinzufügst, muss es immer mindestens
zwei Implementierungen geben, was
dann spannend wird, wenn es irgendwann vielleicht mal kein
Firefox mehr geben sollte, weil der
wirtschaftliche Druck zu groß wird oder nicht.
weil dann wirklich V8 die einzige
Implementierung der Sprache ist.
Da sind wir noch ein Stückchen von weg.
Aber also wie gesagt, ich glaube...
WebKit hat doch auch noch eine eigene
JavaScript-Runtime.
WebKit hat doch auch noch eine eigene.
Ich kenne mich echt nicht so gut aus.
Das stimmt, das ist JS-Core.
Ich denke mal V8 und WebKit.
Safari hat
JS-Core.
Es ist Open Source,
aber es wird anders entwickelt.
Und da kannst du nicht reinschauen,
was da für Entscheidungen wann getroffen werden.
Und dann sprichst du dann halt plötzlich
von, ja wir möchten ja alle
Standards haben, aber diese Standards werden halt von
Konsortien, selbst der
W3C ist ein Konsortium von
Firmen, von großen
Megafirmen, die halt gemeinsam
Webbrowser entwickeln.
Das ist
jetzt auch
nicht so demokratisch, wie der
Autor von diesem Blogpost das jetzt hier
klingen lässt. Hast du zufällig
dieses wunderschöne
von, wie heißt der, Yuval Harari
gelesen, zur
Entwicklung der, beziehungsweise
zur Geschichte der Menschheit.
Nee, aber ich schreibe es mir gerne in meiner
Leseliste. Das ist wirklich ein richtig, richtig gutes
Buch. Der hat auch noch ein weiteres
Homo Deus heißt das, wo er dann quasi
aus der Vergangenheit in seinem ersten Buch bis zum Jetzt geht
und im zweiten Buch quasi von
jetzt in die Zukunft schaut.
Aber der hatte
so ein wunderbares
Ding in seinem Buch,
wo er Konzerne
als die Religion der Moderne bezeichnet,
beziehungsweise dass Notare oder beziehungsweise dass Leute,
die die Möglichkeit haben, also Juristen quasi,
die Zauberer und Schamanen der Neuzeit sind,
weil die Realität schaffen durch Worte, durch Zaubersprüche,
die die sich ausdenken, verändern sie die Realität.
Und wir haben Konzerne in der Form nur,
weil wir als Kollektiv daran glauben, dass die existieren.
Die sind nur auf dem Papier, existieren die und als Kollektiv geben wir denen eine Form und stecken da Dinge rein und dann existiert, in seinem Beispiel war es Peugeot einfach, weil wir an die Existenz von Peugeot glauben und uns zusammengesprochen haben, nur weil wir alle daran glauben, dass dem so ist.
Naja, ein Konzern ist ein Mechanismus, der viele Charakteristika mit einem Organismus teilteilt. Er hat, mal davon abgesehen, dass viele Konzerne juristische Personen sind, haben sie halt einen Überlebensdrang.
Und selbst wenn alle Mitarbeiter der Firma plötzlich kündigen und, gut okay, wenn alle kündigen, dann nicht. Aber wenn ich eine Firma gründe, kann ich mit der Firma machen, was ich will. Und dann habe ich irgendwann, wenn sie groß genug ist, einen Aufsichtsrat, der dafür sorgt, dass die Firma das macht, was die Firma machen soll.
Und dann hast du so ein Hive-Mind quasi.
Und selbst wenn ich dann als Gründer der Firma rausgehe
oder will, dass die Firma was anderes macht,
kann es sein, dass die Firma halt kollektiv entscheidet,
weil es in dem Interesse der Firma ist,
weiter Geld zu verdienen.
Dieses Interesse der Firma wird halt dann selten von einer Person geliefert.
Genau.
Und dann ist es, ich meine, es gibt ja so Firmen,
die machen überhaupt keinen Sinn mehr.
Und dann geht keiner hin und sagt,
wir lösen diese Firma jetzt auf.
Tut mir leid, das ist jetzt alle arbeitslos.
Das passiert nicht.
Die Parallele finde ich eigentlich ganz cool, weil da fällt mir nämlich dieser Vortrag, das war einer der besseren Keynotes, Opening Talks von einem Kongress von vor vier Jahren.
Das war schon in Leipzig, glaube ich, wo quasi argumentiert wurde, Elon Musk hat Angst vor AIs, die die Menschheit übernehmen und der denkt aber dann eher an solchen AIs, halt an Computerprogramme, die dann quasi so Paperclip-Producer sind oder sowas, die einfach so Zeugs produzieren und irgendwie aufgrund eines Bugs eskalieren.
Aber wir haben sowas bereits, es sind Konzerne.
Konzerne sind irgendwie virtuelle Konstrukte, die Menschen für sich arbeiten lassen,
die nicht mehr von einzelnen Menschen gesteuert werden,
die irgendwie einen eigenen Überlebensdrang haben
und die irgendwie durch unsere Gesellschaft durchfunktionieren und irgendwie Effekte haben.
Jetzt können wir noch einen Schritt weiter gehen und diesen Wachstumsdrang mit thematisieren,
dass halt dieser Wunsch da ist,
von so einem
Organismus, wie du es gerade gesagt hast,
immer weiter zu wachsen, immer größer zu werden,
immer mehr Dividenden auszuschütten, was auch immer,
dass das halt nicht für immer tragbar ist
und dass man halt irgendwas finden muss,
um dagegen zu steuern, aber dass man halt nicht
diesem Organismus, also man muss es dem irgendwie
aufzwingen können, aber das ist halt
noch ein ganz anderes Thema. Das habe ich glaube ich vor
vielen Jahren, das war noch
bei den Piraten,
als wir noch diese,
als ich noch bei der Piratenpartei
waren, das war so 2014
rum muss es gewesen sein oder so,
hatten wir so einen Themenabend,
einmal ob alle paar Wochen,
in der K13,
in der Kamenzer Straße, in der Neustadt hier,
in der
Geschäftsstelle
namens Ideenwerkstatt, wo wir einfach
random Dinge besprochen haben.
Irgendwie hat man einen Vortrag vorbereitet zum Thema
der Wahl und dann haben wir darüber gesprochen
und ich habe da was erzählt.
Naiver, junger Kilian,
weird, das könnte
auf YouTube irgendwo,
wo ich erzähle, warum Wachstum
nicht das Maß aller Dinge ist.
Ich habe das wahrscheinlich viel
bessere Erinnerung, als es war und ich könnte mir das nicht mehr anschauen,
weil es viel zu cringy ist.
Prinzipiell thematisiere ich nur so einen Film, der heißt
Growth Busters. Der war toll.
Aber ja, wir schweifen hier komplett ab,
aber gut, das ist das Thema unseres Podcasts.
Ja, also ich
suche nachher nochmal diesen
Keynote vom Kongress raus.
Ich suche euch ganz sicher nicht den Link zu meinem Talk raus.
Nee, aber du kannst dieses Buch nochmal,
diese Reading-List schreiben.
Das finde ich ganz gut. Also ich glaube,
gut, okay, dann können wir von diesem Thema jetzt mal
abweichen.
Also, dass
Microsoft so massiv in das
Open-Source-Ecosystem eingreift,
kann man durchaus kritisieren.
Aber ich denke, sie tun es
durchaus
mit einem Eigeninteresse,
was jetzt nicht unbedingt zum
Nachteil aller ist. Und ich glaube
auch nicht, dass sie irgendwann diesen Extinguished-Schritt
machen, zumindest nicht auf die Art und Weise,
wie sie hier in diesem Blogpost beschrieben ist.
Im Prinzip werden wir es sehen müssen.
Vielleicht sind wir geblendet von der aktuellen
Embrace-Phase.
Oder ist derjenige, der diesen Blogpost
geschrieben hat, der hat jetzt hier nur
626 Reads.
Ist das tatsächlich jemand von uns aus dem Channel gewesen,
der das geschrieben hat?
Nee, Quatsch.
Ich glaube,
das können wir an dieser Stelle hier lassen.
Vielleicht
kommt diese Person halt auch aus der Zukunft
und in fünf Jahren denken wir gerade anders drüber und
denken, oh shit, war mir damals naiv.
Ja, das stimmt, das kann sein.
Weißt du noch, wie wir da saßen und ich irgendwie tatsächlich
für Microsoft argumentiert
habe? Das kann ich mir heute nicht mehr vorstellen.
Kann ich mir auch jetzt nicht vorstellen.
Ich will ja auch nicht für Microsoft argumentieren.
Ich möchte auch nicht mehr. Definitiv hier
Disclaimer, wir machen ja keine
Microsoft-Werbung und
ich finde es auch tatsächlich nicht unbedingt
positiv, dass das alles
aus der gleichen Hand kommt, was ich hier
meinen Lebensunterhalt verdiene, ehrlich gesagt.
Weißt du noch, wie dieser Arschloch-Verein
Aber das ist bei allen anderen Sachen auch so.
Wie dieser Arschloch-Verein vor Jahren
Münchens Initiative für
offene Software
unter Beamten komplett zunichte
gemacht hat.
Das Limux-Projekt.
Wie hat der einen schönen Namen dafür?
Linux für Münden?
Irgendwie sowas war das.
Ich habe mir immer gedacht, geil wäre
der Name
Munix gewesen.
Zu schick.
Aber es ist halt Linux und nicht Unix.
Ja, aber das passt einfach zu gut.
Genau, das gab
dieses Limux-Projekt hieß es, glaube ich.
Hieß es wirklich so? Ich glaube, das hieß Limux.
Wo sie einfach der gesamten Stadtverwaltung
irgendwie Linux-Rechner hingestellt haben.
Limux.
Und dann ist halt Steve Borma
persönlich hingefahren, weil sie natürlich einer
die ganzen... Wir hatten halt Schiss.
Da ist wirklich der Arsch auf Glatteis gegangen,
dass plötzlich, wenn eine
Stadtverwaltung es schafft,
erfolgreich auf nicht
der Office-Suite
zu existieren, dann springen doch
alle anderen von uns ab und dann geht uns richtig,
dann stirbt.
Sie haben sich auch echt Mühe gegeben,
ihre ganzen Office-Zeugs irgendwie webfähig zu machen
und da brauchen sie natürlich auch Web-Entwickler, damit sie
ihr Zeugs am Leben erhalten können.
Also ich schätze mal, das ist ja so ein Mittel zum Zweck.
Die möchten nicht
JavaScript selber kaputt machen, sondern
möchten einfach... Also mein TypeScript wird nur für
Office 365 genutzt. Wahrscheinlich, ja.
Ich weiß, dass ich damals,
das war kurz nach meinem Abi, da habe ich eine
2000...
Ich sag's lieber nicht.
2007 oder so was,
habe ich ein Praktikum bei einer Firma gemacht, die
sich auf die Fahne, das war das irgendwie
das naheliegende Softwarefirma für mich
gewesen zu dem Zeitpunkt.
Also geografisch gesehen.
Und die waren aber größter
Reseller von Microsoft-Lizenzen
und haben nur am Rande so ein bisschen
Software selber entwickelt und ich durfte da
mitmachen, aber eigentlich waren sie halt
Lizenz-Reseller und dann war am
Anfang auch so, das habe ich auch noch nicht
erlebt, da waren halt alle neuen Mitarbeiter
und alle Studenten, die auch gleichzeitig angefangen haben,
also auch ich,
haben dann so ein Zwei-Tage-Workshop gemacht,
wo sie einfach alles einmal vorgestellt bekommen haben.
So viel Zeit haben wir, also zwei Tage am Stück,
wo du wirklich nichts machst, außer so ein Workshop.
Das haben wir auch noch nicht,
das habe ich bei uns in der Firma auch nicht erlebt.
Also die Leute werden geonboardet,
aber du kriegst nicht so ein Zwei-Tage-Indoktrinations-Workshop.
Da saßen die Studenten und ich als Softwareentwickler
und dann noch fünf Leute, die dann Sales
waren und eigentlich für die Leute, die halt Lizenzen
verkaufen sollten, alle mit drin und da fragt
so einer, ja, aber es gibt jetzt ja noch in München,
da haben sie alle ihre
Windows-Lizenzen nicht verlängert und benutzen da jetzt
Linux. Und da hat dann der Typ,
der vorne stand und eigentlich dessen Lebensunterhalt
halt damit verdient hat,
Windows-Lizenzen zu verkaufen,
ja, ja, ja, aber das funktioniert
alles gar nicht und die haben jetzt ganz viele
Windows-Lizenzen gekauft,
weil sie es nämlich gar nicht hinkriegen ohne Windows.
Da haben sich alle kaputt gelacht.
Und ich habe mich dann später gefragt, ist das wirklich so?
Hat hier Limux
irgendwie ganz viele Microsoft-Lizenzen
nochmal neu gekauft?
Die hatten halt, glaube ich, ihre alten Lizenzen
mussten noch auslaufen.
Und für
noch Rechner, die noch nicht umgestellt
waren, wo noch weiter
Windows drauf laufen musste, hatten sie,
und ich wusste gar nicht, dass das geht, hatten sie
gebrauchte Windows-Lizenzen
von irgendeinem
Dritthersteller gekauft, zur Überbrückung.
Okay, witzig.
Und da dachte ich mir, okay, ich wusste gar nicht, dass man irgendwie
von Resellern quasi so als
so Auflöseware oder sowas wahrscheinlich
Windows-Lizenzen
nachkaufen kann. Und da haben sie quasi,
während sie die einen Rechner auf Linux umgestellt haben,
haben sie die anderen irgendwie auf ein anderes Windows umgestellt, zur Überbrückung.
Witzig.
Aber prinzipiell ist das Projekt ja leider gescheitert, weil Microsoft
da haben sie die Propagandemaschine aufgefahren.
Da ist das, gut,
man kann natürlich sagen, das waren noch zu Steve-Bormer-Zeiten
und Steve-Bormer hat ja generell irgendwie
wieder Mensch gewesen.
Developer, Developer, Developer,
Developer, Monkey Boy,
Bomber auf der Runde. Aber ich meine, gut,
die Firma hat halt
diese Geschichte und die Firma hat halt,
wie gesagt, die bauen Werbung
in ihr Betriebssystem ein, die haben immer noch
viel Mist, den sie auch machen.
Und man kann
Microsoft nicht gut reden
an der Stelle, weil sie halt zu viel Dreck am Strecken haben,
auch immer noch, auch aktuellen Dreck.
Aber um
das Thema, hoffentlich damit absolut, wie du es gerade eben schon
machen wolltest, an dem Beispiel sehe ich es
nicht. An dem Beispiel machen sie vieles
gut und richtig.
Und wie gesagt, das ist nicht mein Stack.
Ich nutze GitHub sehr gerne.
Sehr, sehr gerne. Und ich bin auch glücklich, dass
die da Geld reinpumpen, damit das weiterlebt.
Und anscheinend GitHub
nur besser machen und nicht GitHub zu LinkedIn machen.
Was ich auch gekauft habe.
Stimmt.
Die Leute,
der einen Leute findest du hier, die anderen Leute findest du da.
Was ich auch scheiße finde, ist,
dass das quasi so ein Industriestandardverhalten geworden ist,
dass du, wenn jemanden einstellst, erst mal schaust,
hat der ein GitHub-Profil.
Und ich weiß, dass ich jahrelang alles,
was ich zu Studienzeiten, was ich gehackt habe,
habe ich einfach so auf GitHub gepackt,
weil ich mir gedacht habe, irgendwann guckt sich das mal jemand an
und dann hilft mir das, den Job zu finden.
Und tatsächlich, man benutzt es natürlich,
um sich ein Bild zu machen.
Ich benutze es auch, wenn sich jemand bewirbt, schaue ich, hat der sowas?
Ich verlange jetzt nicht, dass es jemand hat.
Wir haben auch jetzt Leute eingestellt, die überhaupt nichts auf GitHub haben.
Aber wenn du dann natürlich nachvollziehen kannst, was schreibt der so, was kann der so?
Wenn du halt einen Einblick so finden kannst in die Art und Weise, was die Person damit online stellt, ist das schon mal super.
Aber man darf es halt nicht voraussetzen.
Oder auch nur diesen Bias im Kopf haben, dass wenn die Person nichts hat, dass du direkt so ein äh im Hinterkopf hast, das ist halt auch schon scheiße.
Aber wenn du halt die Möglichkeit hast, da auch aktuelle Sachen zu sehen und was die Person so macht.
Oder wenn das halt ein, keine Ahnung,
wenn es ein Pluspunkt ist für die Person, super.
Aber es darf halt kein Negativpunkt sein.
Das ist das, was du, glaube ich, sagst.
Genau, auf jeden Fall.
Einer der größten Vorteile für mich von GitHub,
ich habe das letztens erst festgestellt,
ich bastle ja, wie wir schon ein paar Mal gesprochen haben,
mit so einem Matrix-Client namens Neo
und komme da jetzt in,
gerade in letzter Zeit in der Pandemie
habe ich so ein bisschen den Flow verloren,
einfach nur, weil sich viele andere Sachen
immer noch aufhäufen.
Dabei sagen doch alle, wir haben jetzt so viel Zeit
viel Langeweile, das versteht nicht irgendwie unsere Regale
ausmisten und irgendwie
Brot backen.
Das stimmt nicht.
Man hat irgendwie gefühlt weniger Zeit
für alle. Ich weiß auch nicht, wie das funktioniert.
Aber
vor kurzem habe ich einen neuen
Contributor gefunden, beziehungsweise der hat das Projekt gefunden
und der hat so
viel geilen Scheiß gemacht.
Ja, also ein Feature nach dem
anderen. Kann ich Element jetzt schon deinstallieren eigentlich
oder nicht? Wenn du
auf Verschlüsselung stehst, lieber doch nicht.
Aber
der erste Schritt zu
End-to-End-Verschlüsselung ist
getan in Nio. Du kannst
verschlüsselte Nachrichten versenden, du kannst sie empfangen,
solange der Client läuft. Du verlierst beim
Neustart die Session-Keys, deswegen
ist es immer noch nutzlos quasi.
Weil hier noch keinen sicheren Storage für die Keys kann.
Die werden einfach nicht gespeichert aktuell. Wahrscheinlich ist das
auch nur ein Flag, das noch gesetzt werden muss im SDK,
aber das haben wir einfach nicht getan, weil die
Doku zum SDK nicht existiert.
Aber
Es ist halt ein erster Schritt und du kannst jetzt die History komplett nachladen aus deinen Chats,
was halt so ein essentielles Messungs-Office war, was halt noch nie drin war in Nio bisher.
Du kannst neue Chats starten und das ist eine super slicken UI.
Gefühlt alle zwei Tage merge ich ein PR, wo jemand eine neue Sprache hinzugefügt hat zu den Übersetzungen.
Also Nio kannst du schon in Norwegian Bokmal dir anschauen.
Das ist der Hammer.
Und sowas wäre halt nicht passiert, wenn ich Nio privat irgendwo baue,
beziehungsweise wenn ich Neo nicht auf GitHub
entwickle, weil GitHub halt so eine Anlaufstelle ist.
Natürlich könnte man sowas wie GitHub-O-Telig-Distreiber,
aber das macht halt das so
easy, dass Leute das finden
und contributen und
Kram machen und das, also
ich finde es so herrlich, diesen Typen gefunden zu haben.
Ich weiß, dass Doug diesen Podcast
nicht hört, weil Doug aus der UK kommt, aber
holy shit, Doug, was ein geiler Typ.
Ja, das meinte ich,
Open Source funktioniert auf unterschiedlichen
Skalen anders als
du als kleiner, das ist genau dieses Beispiel,
du als kleiner Entwickler,
du machst ja Neo nicht, um damit reich zu werden.
Ich wüsste nicht mehr, wie ich das mal klar gesehen habe.
Das ist dann das Problem.
Du als kleiner bist froh, wenn du jemanden findest,
der dir irgendwie die Tickets abnimmt.
Ich profitiere unheimlich von der Zentralisation von GitHub.
Aber wenn du dann irgendwann diesen Punkt überschreitest,
bei vielen ist das ja so,
du fängst so ein Projekt an als Open Source,
du machst es bloß zum Spaß, aus Liebe,
Dann wird das erfolgreich und beliebt und plötzlich sagt einer,
weißt du was, du könntest doch damit Geld verdienen,
mach doch eine Firma draus.
Und dann kommen diese ganzen moralischen,
das ist kein richtiger Open Source mehr,
die Geschichten zustande, wo dann plötzlich Monetarisierungsfeatures einkommen.
Dann hast du vielleicht irgendwann Kunden, dann brauchst du Telemetry,
dann betreibst du Infrastruktur, oder selbst wenn du Infrastruktur betreibst,
brauchst du irgendwie Telemetry.
Und dann sagst du, gut, okay, dann müssen wir jetzt auch eine Strategie entwickeln, weil wir sind ja eine Firma, dann brauchen wir eine Roadmap, wo wir hingehen wollen.
Und sobald du dann auch eine Strategie und eine Roadmap hast, nimmst du nicht mehr von jedem jede wilde Contribution von der Seite rein, die nicht in deine Roadmap passt.
Und dann bist du zwar immer noch irgendwie Open Source, weil du nie aufgehört hast, Open Source zu sein, aber du kannst natürlich deine Strategie gar nicht mehr so fahren, wie du das am Anfang gemacht hast, wo du dich über jeden gefreut hast, der irgendwie mal ein neues Feature für dich eingebaut hat.
oder contributed hat. Das ist dann einfach nicht mehr genau dasselbe.
Und so ist es halt
bei vielen Open-Source-Projekten, die so
zu Guck-Open-Source sind, wo du denkst,
das ist ja...
Die wollen ja bloß irgendwie ihr
Image verbessern,
indem sie hier Open-Source machen,
was aber gar nicht wirklich Open-Source ist.
Ja, Open-Source sind halt auch Sachen.
Zu Guck-Open-Source ist halt auch Open-Source.
Gut, du kannst natürlich sagen, dass das nicht das ist, was du meintest, aber
ich meine, ich habe keine Ahnung,
wie sich mein Projekt hier weiterentwickelt.
Wahrscheinlich sagt auch irgendeiner, ich habe hier
geforkt, weil Neo war mir nicht frei genug.
Hier erstmal die freie Variante von Neo.
Ja, schau. Das Neo hat schon dieses schön freie
Apache-Lizenz.
Das ist sowas wie Chat-Secure, ne?
Oder Text-Secure.
Wir forken jetzt Signal, weil sie das
SMS-Feature ausgebaut haben. Das kann dir immer passieren.
Ja, was passiert denn, wenn das Ding hier populär ist?
Wenn Matrix durchstartet, weil es halt
meiner Meinung nach die beste Plattform ist
für Konversationen.
Wenn Neo populär ist.
Es sei denn, du möchtest Threads haben.
Kommt noch irgendwann, hoffentlich.
Ja, natürlich.
Zu dem Thema ganz kurz.
Ich möchte Threads demnächst mal Neo einbauen
und ich möchte es genauso machen, wie iMessage das macht.
Und ich finde das super geil,
dass du in iMessage ein Thread hast,
du tippst den Thread an
und die Nachrichten aus dem Thread
sammeln sich quasi zusammen
und du siehst nur den Thread,
aber jede von den Nachrichten wurde in den Mainline-Chat
trotzdem geschickt.
Und das finde ich die eleganteste Variante.
Ist das geil?
Ich weiß, dass das Feature gibt es bei Slack.
diesen Haken setzen,
dass es auch im Mainline-Channel landet.
Das benutze ich nie und wenn ich das mache,
wenn das jemand macht, finde ich es verwirrend, ehrlich gesagt.
Entweder ist es ein Teil von dem Thread,
dann ist die Parent-Message
die oder es ist halt
nicht in dem Thread.
Wahrscheinlich ist das so ein Ding, dass du,
also ich verstehe, dass dieser Haken
in Slack existiert und ich persönlich finde
den sehr wertvoll, wenn du
eine Nachricht in einem Thread hast, die für
alle relevant ist, weil sobald der Thread aus dem
Bildschirm rausgescrollt ist, ist der quasi
unsichtbar für die Leute, die nicht Teil von dem Thread sind,
weil niemand scrollt hoch.
Auf der anderen Seite ist wahrscheinlich gerade so...
Du willst es nicht für alle Nachrichten machen.
Dann bräuchtest du keine Threads.
Natürlich nicht. Beziehungsweise habe ich ja gerade argumentiert,
dass ich das so haben möchte.
Prinzipiell ist es ja auch so ein Ding,
dass zwischen kleinen Chats
und großen Chats, in einem Raum, wo
tausend Leute drin sind, willst du nicht alles in Mainline-Spam.
In einem Raum, wo fünf Leute drin sind, will ich
explizit alles in den Mainline-Chats
haben, aber die Threads trotzdem
als Threat-Möglichkeit haben. Und da hast du halt
den Mehrwert wieder drin.
Das ist dann aber eine Darstellungsfrage.
Genau, das ist eine reine Darstellungsfrage. Und das macht es
eben cool. Für kleine Räume. Für große
Räume brauchst du Threats, die nicht
im Mainline-Challenge sind.
Threats sind per se
immer dasselbe. Und dann kannst du
halt auf der View-Ebene sagen,
bitte linearisiere mir mal bitte
diese Ansicht.
Das ist exakt das, was
iMessage macht.
Ich zeige es dir mal kurz.
Kannst du ja noch ausschneiden, ob du irgendwas finden willst.
Hier sind Threads.
Hier hat Lars eine Nachricht geschrieben, die Reply auf diese Nachricht war.
Wenn ich diese Nachricht antippe, dann zieht er das quasi
in der Video-Ebene raus und macht mit dem Thread.
Und ich kann hier das Reply und das landet in dem Thread.
Dieses Telefon ist gigantisch groß, ganz ehrlich.
Ich hab mich dran gewöhnt.
Das ist geil.
Ja, aber es kann passieren.
Also Matrix
ist wirklich,
ich meine gut, dasselbe hätte ich vor 10 Jahren
von Jabber gesagt, aber Matrix ist,
was dadurch gerade das ist
von jetzt irgendwie der
unterschiedlichen Regierungs...
Matrix hat das Potenzial, das zu sein, was Jepperd hätte sein sollen.
Matrix
hat halt das Potenzial,
E-Mail endlich abzulösen.
Ich meine, theoretisch
schon. Die Frage ist,
ich persönlich will das, glaube ich,
nicht, weil ich
unterschiedliche Werte da sehe,
aber theoretisch kannst du E-Mail
neu bauen, auf Matrix aufsetzen, die
Clients genau gleich aussehen lassen.
Aber genau das war halt bei Jabber auch schon so. Also ich will
diese Jabber versus Matrix Diskussion
nicht... Bei Jabber versus Matrix sehe ich
nicht. Prinzipiell machen die
beide genau das gleiche. Der Nachteil von Jabber ist
halt nur, es ist schon so lange da
und irgendwie startet es nicht durch.
Das ist der einzige wirkliche Nachteil
von Jabber. Aber Jabber kann so viel mehr als
Matrix. Das ist eigentlich krass. Ja, aber das ist halt
das war halt auch noch, das ist auch so ein bisschen, das war halt
ein verteiltes Ökosystem,
was nie so richtig zusammengefunden hat. Da gab es halt
unterschiedliche Clients, die alle ziemlich geil waren
das doch krass ist. Ah, alle? Es gibt zwei Clients,
die gut sind. Früher war es
mal anders, klar. Naja, aber jetzt,
guck mal, jetzt gibt es Matrix, da gibt es Element.
Matrix ist noch gar kein Kleiner.
So, und, und, und ich meine,
hier gibt es jetzt diesen vielversprechenden,
zukunftsträchtigen
iOS-Clients, der gar nichts kann.
Aber es kann ja auch mal
passieren, dass irgendwie das, dass das
Bundesministerium für irgendwas kommt und sagt,
so, wir haben jetzt hier überall
Outlook abgeschafft und machen
keine E-Mails mehr.
Und unsere Kollegen schicken sich jetzt alle Matrix-Nachrichten
und bitte bau doch mal in diesen Client,
den wir jetzt auf den ganzen Dienst,
iPhones,
nee, das passiert nicht,
den wir jetzt auf den ganzen Dienst zählen.
Ja, aber technisch möglich ist das ja, was du sagst.
Und wir heuern dich jetzt an
und deine Firma,
die vorher mit diesem Open-Source-New-Client angefangen hat,
hat jetzt als Business-Modell
irgendwie Special-Features da einzubauen
für irgendwie bestimmte Kunden,
die Matrix benutzen.
Es gibt eine kleine Firma in Deutschland,
die heißt Famitly,
machen exakt das
für das Gesundheitssystem. Die bauen
Matrix-Clients nicht
wirklich für
F-A-M-E-D-L-Y
mit E
statt I.
Famedly.
Famedly, genau. Ich weiß auch nicht, wie man das wirklich
ausspricht. Aber
die wollen die Plattform, seine Kommunikationsplattform
zwischen Ärzten und Laboren
und Krankenhäusern nicht wirklich für
den Patienten. Das kommt vielleicht später.
aber erstmal für das dahinter.
Und die sind gerade stark am
expandieren und bauen damit aus.
Und das kommt auf Matrix auf. Das ist ein Matrix-Startup.
Cool.
Und die Leute dahinter sind auch
sehr bekannt in der Matrix-Welt, aber prinzipiell
es geht ja in die Richtung
von dem, was du sagst.
Und ich meine, das hat auch, dass die Bundeswehr
schon auf Matrix setzt und dass die französische Regierung
auf Matrix setzt.
Die französische Regierung hat vorher Projekte
gemacht, wo sie die Wahlergebnisse
ihrer Präsidentschaftswahlen mit
staatlich geforderten Jabba-Service
verteilt haben. Immer noch besser, was wir hier
gerade machen.
Ja, das stimmt. Hast du noch diesen Talk
vom Kongress im Kopf,
von dem Deutschen Weißestee?
Ja, ja, ja.
What the fuck?
Das passiert halt, wenn so ein Ding einmal läuft und du sagst,
wozu muss ich das weiterentwickeln?
Wir haben diese eine Firma,
der geben wir seit 15 Jahren
Geld, damit es funktioniert.
Aber es funktioniert nur, weil halt niemand
hinschaut und alle machen die Augen
auf jeden Fall.
Naja, gut, okay. Da war aber trotzdem
kein Innovationsdruck da auf allen Seiten.
Du kannst aber nicht mal sicherstellen, dass die Zahlen
nicht verändert wurden. Das ist ja
von Grund auf schon broken.
Das hat nie den Einsatzzweck erfüllt.
Naja, aber es hat sich kein Mensch für
interessiert.
Da war halt kein
Innovationsdruck von den Beteiligten,
weder von den Regierungen noch von der Firma, die ja
tatsächlich Arbeitsleistung
hätte investieren müssen, um das Produkt,
was sie eh schon verkaufen.
Warum?
Das ist ja nur,
wenn du die Augen zu, wenn du quasi
squintest und hinschaust, ist das ein MVP, was die
gemacht haben. Und das ist halt das, was
seit 15 Jahren nutzt.
Ja, das ist so nach dem Motto,
der Sohn von der Frau Schneider
hat da mal was programmiert,
der macht sowas gerne. Es gibt doch auch,
dass irgendwo Software läuft,
die von Leuten, von Abiturienten
gebaut wurde oder sowas.
Und ups, jetzt nutzt es die Bundesregierung.
Ja, klar. Solche Software
gibt es immer. Und das Problem ist, wenn
so ein MVP einmal läuft und sich verkauft,
dann ist halt irgendwie plötzlich
das Interesse gar nicht
mehr da, da jetzt noch weiter Ressourcen reinzustecken.
Das geht doch. Warum denn?
Egal.
Das war jetzt quasi
das Thema.
Wo waren wir als letztes stehen geblieben?
Schreibt uns, wo wir aufgehört haben.
Übrigens, was ich vorhin noch spontan mit auf die Liste
gepackt habe, weil wir bei NPM waren.
Wir haben den letzten NPM-Fuck-Up gar nicht thematisiert.
Ach nein, erzähl.
Dieser herrliche Fuck-Up, dass wenn du...
die Möglichkeit, private Specs
Repos anzulegen. Du hast Dependencies
in deinen Node-Projekten, die
für deine Firma spezifisch sind, die du lokal
hostest, die in deinem
VPN zugänglich sind und die nur von
da aus jetzt laden werden und
als Dependencies reingezogen werden in deine Projekte.
Und das Problem, was hier
jemand bemerkt hatte, war, dass
NPM
wohl bei Default
nicht irgendeine Reihenfolge
beachtet, wo die Dependencies herkommen,
sondern erstmal Public NPM
durchsucht nach den Dependencies.
Der NPM-Client.
Okay, vielleicht können wir das nochmal kurz
anders herleiten.
Also NPM kann man
irgendwie konfigurieren, dass man sagt,
alle Dependencies, die in meiner
Package-JSON stehen, die mit
mein aktueller Firmenname
anfangen,
die machst du bitte mal Lookup und dann
schaust du bitte nicht direkt bei npm.js.com
nach, sondern
die findest du dort definitiv nicht,
sondern die findest du immer bloß in unserem Lokalen
und bei uns ist jetzt gerade sowas wie
Artifactory, womit du dann dein eigenes Package
holst. Genau, das meine ich,
aber anscheinend ist das broken, wenn
das Package mit dem Namen auch
Public existiert, dann wird nämlich präferiert
das genommen.
Das heißt, wenn du weißt, wie eine private
Dependency von der Firma heißt, dann
lame-squatest du das einfach und machst da bösen
Chartcode rein und die ziehen das dann
automatisch.
Und anscheinend ist es genauso broken bei
PyPyre und bei RubyGems, bloß, dass
die beiden nur
dann failen würden, wenn eine
höhere Versionsnummer existiert. Aber dann pusht du
einfach eine Version 9 davon
und dann ist die ja neu.
Beziehungsweise je nachdem, wie du halt deine
Dependency-Pins festgemacht hast, dass du halt
up to next major, also solange du weißt,
was ja relativ easy ranzukommen ist, weil du bei einer Firma
gearbeitet hast oder weil du Kontakt hast da,
solange du weißt, wie das intern heißt,
die Dependency, und in die Versionsbracket
reinpoken kannst, kannst du halt
anscheinend auf NPM
oder achst du das bei Swift nicht so?
Bei Swift hast du halt keine zentrale...
Dadurch, dass wir keinen Index haben,
haben wir halt dieses Problem gar nicht,
weil du halt ein Package angibst mit seiner fully qualified URL
und da kannst du halt die anderen Injection.
Du kannst es auf DNS-Ebene theoretisch umleiten,
aber das kannst du überall.
Aber das klang herrlich broken,
also richtig so Next-Level-Broken.
Wie ist das noch nie jemandem aufgefallen?
Naja, also auf der anderen Seite,
das sind solche Sachen ja auch immer nur NPM-Fuck-Ups,
weil NPM irgendwie der Vorreiter in diesem Space ist.
Die sind groß und das merkt man sehr schnell,
wenn da Fuck-ups sind.
Weil du sagst ja, bei
RubyGems ist es das gleiche Problem.
Bei Rust ist es auch kein Problem,
weil sich da noch keiner sein eigenes Crates
hosten kann. Da gibt es immer noch keine lokalen
Registries. Das ist, glaube ich, technisch möglich,
aber ich glaube, es gibt noch keine großen
stabilen. Also macht man das nicht?
Oder wie baut man was zur privaten Dependentation?
Es gibt jetzt erst mehr und mehr
Firmen, die Interesse daran haben.
Wie hat man das bisher gemacht? Gab es doch bestimmt schon
die Möglichkeit. Keine Ahnung, weiß ich nicht.
weiß ich nicht.
Die Rust-Firmen haben einfach immer
alles Open-Source-of-Packages.
Was kommt denn dazu?
Ich hatte es auch noch vorgeschlagen, ich würde das ja auch gerne
irgendwie auf Arbeit nutzen und ich habe dann festgestellt,
zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo ich das letzte Mal geguckt habe, gab es noch nicht
die Möglichkeit, sich sein eigenes... Also Artifactory konnte
man noch nicht sagen, hier hoste
mal bitte Rust-Packages. Artifactory ist
einfach so ein Dienst, der quasi
für verschiedene Backends, sei das jetzt Gradle,
sei das Maven, sei das sonst was,
dass lokal hosten kann
die Registries dafür.
Bei unseren Projekten gibt es eine NPM-RC,
die von Jahren gelesen wird und nicht von NPM.
Deswegen würde mich mal interessieren,
ob das dieser NPM-Fuck ist, ist ja ein Kleinzeit-Problem.
Ob das bei den fünf anderen NPM-Alternativen,
die es ja auch gibt, da gibt es irgendwie PNPM und Jarn
und Jarn2, die alle, und Dino,
die das vielleicht irgendwie, ob die das vielleicht auch machen.
Und dann hätten, das wäre doof.
Ich dachte eigentlich, naja,
der Scher geschrieben, dieser Namespace,
den findet ihr dort, wenn der sich der Client
dann natürlich beim Unterladen daran hält.
Gleich mal unseren Firmennamen hier bei...
Nee, nee, nee.
Sondern du squattest, alles gut oder was?
Ich hab da mal zur Sicherheit alle
unsere Packages... Nicht, dass
ihr denkt, dass ich unsere internen
Libraries jetzt auf NPM
geschoben habe. Ich hab die nur gesquattet, damit
da nichts passiert.
Das ist der Fix.
Das gab's irgendwie...
In irgendeinem Ding war ein Test drin,
dass dieses...
Genau, es gab da diesen Fix
diesen WannaCry-Dings,
wo der
auf irgendeine URL zugegriffen hat
und wenn es die nicht gab
oder so, dann hat er nicht mehr
funktioniert.
Ach nee, die haben irgendwie
meinst du zufällig das, wo, das hat sich
der Daniel Stenberg, der Curl-Entwickler,
darüber aufgeregt, dass irgendeine Seite,
wo du mit Curl was
abgreifen konntest, beziehungsweise du konntest mit Curl testen,
beziehungsweise das Test-Skript,
die Leute, die es online geteilt haben,
wie man diesen Exploit findet, haben das mit Curl
gezeigt, was der Exploit war. Und was die
gemacht haben, ist haben den Default-User-Agent von Curl
oder so geblockiert einfach.
Das ist halt kein Fix dafür.
Ich weiß nicht, dass es war.
Es gab irgendwas, das hat bei einem...
Achso, es gab eine Seite, die war...
Die wurde
von dem WannaCry...
Korrigiert mich bitte. Ich glaub, das Ding hat getestet,
ob's nur im richtigen Internet war
oder ob das irgendwie auf einer geblockten Kiste war.
Wenn das Ding halt auf einer Kiste ist,
die nicht... Wenn dein Virus oder
nicht Spyware, sondern
deine
Ransomware auf einer Kiste läuft,
die nicht zum Internet
zugreifen kann, dann soll die auch
nicht loslaufen, weil dann kannst
du die Keys nicht austauschen
und dann kriegst du, können die Leute,
du willst ja, dass dein Kunde zufrieden ist,
wenn die dir ihre 300 Bitcoins überweisen
oder so, was man da gemacht hat,
dann möchtest du denen die Keys
zum Entschütteln auch wieder zustellen können.
Und deswegen hat dieses Ding einfach
schreiben. Genau, und deswegen hat dieses Dings
gecheckt,
bin ich in einem richtigen Internet, habe ich Zugriff zum
Internet und das hat es gemacht, indem es auf einer
Webseite zugreifen hat. Aha. Und wenn es
diese Webseite erreicht hat,
dann hat es gesagt,
da, ne, ist ja falsch rum
eigentlich, dann hat es gesagt, ich
laufe jetzt nicht los. Ne, dann läuft es los, wenn es
die Webseite erreicht hat. Die haben halt die Webseite blockiert.
Ich dachte, jemand hat einfach,
ach ne, wir haben einen Killswitch
gehabt auf der Domain und jemand hat die Domain registriert.
Genau, so rum war das. Aha.
Die hat einfach die ganze Zeit einen Check gemacht auf eine random generierte
Seite, die aber fest gehardcoded war
auf irgendeinem Random String. Und wenn
da was zu finden ist, dann war da einfach ein Killswitch für
das Ding, warum auch immer dieser Killswitch drin war.
Das weiß man ja nicht, weil man die Person nicht kennt, die jetzt geschrieben
hatte. So war das. Ich überlege jetzt nochmal,
ob ich diese Sektion hier drin lasse.
Wir beleiten uns live die
Storys wieder her, aus unserer Erinnerung.
Okay.
Das war also der NPM-Fuck-Up, man
sollte, und das ist jetzt aber gefixt, ja?
Keine Ahnung.
Dann pack doch mal den linken.
Ich hab das in so einen Arbeitslack gepackt
und meine Android-Kollegen haben mal gesagt,
mit Maven haben wir dieses Problem auch.
Wir schauen mal irgendwie sowas.
Aber apropos gerade,
weil du Ransomware angesprochen hast,
was ich so cool fand, weil ich irgendwie noch im Hinterkopf hab,
irgendeine Ransomware oder irgendeine generelle Schadsoftware
gab es, die hatte als Command-and-Control-Server
nicht eigentlich ihre eigenen Server,
sondern die haben das so,
ich muss sagen, clever
versteckt, dass die einfach
Requests gemacht hat auf Instagram,
auf Britney Spears
Instagram Account und in den
Kommentaren dort
waren die Anweisungen für die
Schadsoftware, aber halt
maskiert als echte
Kommentare. Da sahen aus wie
Kommentare unter Britney Spears.
Keine Ahnung, was man da so schreibt.
Sowas in der Richtung, aber das
quasi als versteckter Code,
als CNC-Surfer
für die Schadsoftware.
Diese Idee finde ich so mega cool,
Das ist so richtig.
Du siehst natürlich, dass deine Rechner
möglicherweise Requests zu Instagram machen.
Okay, weird, aber das könnte natürlich auch
legitimer sein. Aber find mal, dass das
der CNC-Server ist,
weil die Person in den Kommentaren
den Code versteht. Wie klug
ist das?
Es gab ja vorher schon CNC-Server, die irgendwie über
IAC funktioniert haben und die haben
sich diese ganzen Bots dann einfach, waren Bot-Networks,
die haben sich bei irgendwelchen Chaträumen angemeldet.
Das Internet-Relay-Chat
hat halt auch klasse geeignet, weil du hast nirgendwo
diesen Log,
das wird einfach verteilt an die Kleinen und fertig.
Das ist immer so ein Protokollmissbrauch.
Das ist kein Missbrauch, das ist ein
1A-Use-Case für IRC.
Irgendjemand hatte mir auch mal ein super geiles
Konzept beschrieben, wie er sowas wie
BitTorrent auf Twitter basierend
implementieren würde, das kannst du auch...
Was war das, als YouTube-DL
runtergenommen wurde und jemand
die Packages
Taubal einfach kodiert in zwei Grafiken
auf Twitter hochgeladen hatte.
Ah, ja, ja, genau.
Beziehungsweise, das haben wir, glaube ich, mal angesprochen gehabt, oder?
Ja, ja.
Weil dieser DMCA-PR, okay, nevermind.
Gut, okay, ich setze an dieser Stelle mal eine Kapitelmarke.
Wollen wir zu den Picks übergehen?
Kilian ist im Nano-Hype.
Ach, das habe ich auch noch drauf geschrieben.
Okay, ich versuche es mal in weniger als einer halben Stunde,
das Thema.
Nein, nein, lass dir Zeit, ich habe sonst nichts mehr vor heute.
Ich habe in der letzten Zeit mal wieder mich mehr im Altcoin, also im Cryptocurrency-Feld umgeschaut und eine Currency entdeckt, die schon länger da ist.
Ach, du meinst nicht Nano den Editor, sondern?
Ne, ich meine nicht Nano, die
Cryptocurrency.
Weil Nano
ist, ich habe
das gefunden und bin
begeistert, das ist das, was Bitcoin
immer sein wollte, aber
nicht ist. Ich meine, wir sehen jetzt,
wo Bitcoin... Also Bitcoin ist eigentlich nicht mehr
zu gebrauchen, um sich damit seinen Burger oder sowas zu kaufen.
Bitcoin war noch nie zu gebrauchen. Ich meine, wir haben
das damals mal im ASCII-Spaßentag benutzt, um ein paar
Mater zu verkaufen. Genau, wir wollten das ja durchsetzen,
damit wir sowas machen können.
Aber es wurden halt immer die offensichtlichen
Flans gezeigt, von wegen, du brauchst 10 Minuten,
um eine Bestätigung für den Blog zu bekommen,
um die Transaktion.
Weil das hat gesehen, dass halt alle sagen, das ist anonym
und das stimmt überhaupt nicht.
Das ist richtig, es ist pseudonym an der
Stelle, aber
allein von dem Anonymitätsaspekt,
weil den hast du in Nano genauso wenig,
aber da kommen wir gleich nochmal drauf zu.
Das Hauptproblem von Bitcoin
momentan, dass es einfach eine Wertanlage
anstatt Gold ist und nicht was, womit man so sehr
ein Kaugummi anhand. Es ist eine Wertanlage, weil
Bitcoin limitiert ist in der Transaktionszeit
Nummer 1,
weil du halt, ich glaube, das
Limit ist aktuell bei 7 Transaktionen
pro Sekunde. Dafür ist es einfach
keine Möglichkeit für
globale... Weltweit 7
Transaktionen pro Sekunde. Weltweit 7 Transaktionen
pro Sekunde ist das, was aktuell ist. Ich weiß, dass ich teilweise,
und das ist 3 Jahre her, lange gewartet habe,
bis meine Transaktion durchführt. Ja, weil du halt...
Transaktionen sind gebührenpflichtig,
also haha-pflichtig
in Anführungsstrichen. Weil diejenigen, die das meinen,
bezahlen müssen. Genau, weil die Leute, die bestätigen
aus dem Pool
von allen Transaktionen natürlich diejenigen,
die ihnen Geld geben. Logisch. Ergibt Sinn,
das Incentive ist da, die
Transaktionen mit den höchsten Gebühren sich einzusammeln,
weil damit kriegst du auch am meisten Geld
als Miner. Und dadurch, dass du als Miner
schon an razor-scharfen
Margins arbeitest, weil du halt
extrem hohe Energiekosten hast,
musst du dir natürlich die Transaktion nehmen.
Wenn du nicht gerade dir so einen alten
Staudamm-Wasserkraftwerk-Dings
da gekauft hast. Ja, aber so oder so,
du willst halt maximal Geld damit verdienen.
Und willst halt Geld damit verdienen.
Und das musst du halt.
Einen Staudamm kriegst du auch nicht geschenkt.
Sondern hast du entweder selber gebaut
oder hast die Möglichkeit dazu.
Aber da hängen halt auch Kosten mit dran.
Und Bitcoin kostet unglaubliche Mengen an Energie.
Und Bitcoin hat dementsprechend für den Endnutzer,
für die Leute, die damit Geld überweisen wollen,
die Transaktionsgebühren,
die aktuell irgendwo zwischen 5 und nach oben
offen Euro sind, pro Transaktion.
Ach, bei 5 Euro geht's los. Also,
weniger als das kannst du versuchen,
aber es kann sein, dass deine Transaktion
einfach nicht durchgeht. Also, mittlerweile ist halt
Bitcoin sowas, wo halt
Tesla sich 1,5
Milliarden. Milliarden Dollar
reininvestiert, um irgendwo
Geld hinzulegen. Ich meine, Elon ist ein
Meme-Lord ohne das Gleiche, aber ich glaube auch so,
dass Tesla als
Konzern, als Hive meint,
er hat da nicht die Möglichkeit, einfach 1,5 Milliarden
einfach, äh, bestimmt hat er die Möglichkeit, aber
nicht, dass er das einfach nur for the lols
gemacht hat, sondern, ich meine, Bitcoin ist
eine fantastische Wertanlage, wenn es sich weiter
so verhält, weil Bitcoin als
Konzept super ist, also
Bitcoin hat uns viel gebracht als Idee und
aktuell ist es eine Wertanlage,
weil es eine Wertanlage ist, also
so ein bisschen so eine selbstverfüllende Prophezeiung.
Es hat die kritische Masse schon längst überschritten.
Das auf jeden Fall.
Im Gegensatz zu vielen solchen kleinen
... Genau, aber du hast
halt Probleme. Bitcoin ist keine
Currency, die es sein wollte, weil du halt
dieses Bullshit-Limit von sieben Transaktionen pro Sekunde hast,
worüber du nicht wirklich
hinauskommst, weil die Blockgröße, also die Menge
an Transaktionen in einem Block ist fest
und die Menge
an Blocks pro Zeit ist fest. Also es wird
ein Block pro zehn Minuten gemeint. Daran
macht sich ja fest... Ich muss schon wieder an Minecraft denken.
Daran
macht sich ja fest diese Komplexität des Mines.
Damit ist so dynamisch eingestellt,
dass ein Block alle zehn Minuten rausfällt.
Das ist
das Protokoll... Ich muss noch an Minecraft denken.
Ist ja auch so.
Gibt es eigentlich auch welche
Bitcoin-Clients, die irgendwie Redstone
heißen oder was?
Jedenfalls ist das halt an der Stelle
ein bisschen blöd und der Transaktionszeit,
dadurch, dass du warten musst, mindestens 10 Minuten,
im Idealfall eine Stunde, um sicher
zu gehen, dass die Transaktion so richtig ist.
Also es ist nicht mehr funktional für die kleinen Maßstäbe.
Dafür war es nie funktional.
Wir haben im ASCII Mathe verkauft und haben einfach
hingenommen, ich sehe die Transaktion, ich gebe dir die
Mathe jetzt einfach, obwohl die nicht confirmed ist, wenn du
versuchen würdest, ein Double Spend zu machen.
Wäre das ASCII-Mate-Geld jemals wieder in echtes Geld umgewandelt?
Nö.
Hätten wir das laut sagen dürfen?
Quatsch.
Nee.
Jegliche Bitcoin-Zahlungen im ASCII, die wir gemacht haben, liefen so ab, dass die Zahlung Bitcoin an mich ging.
Und ich auf der Anstreitliste quasi die Zahlung dem ASCII weitergereicht habe.
Gute Art und Weise ist Geld zu waschen, ehrlich gesagt.
Sicherlich.
Und ich meine, wenn du dir den Bitcoin-Kurs so anschaust, ich habe die ASCII-Bitcoin immer noch.
also für mich hat sich das sehr rentiert,
wenn ich das jetzt verkaufen würde.
Aber Bitcoin ist eine Währanlage und keine Währung.
Und dieses Prinzip Währung,
Cryptocurrency global für alle,
eine Währung, die nicht
überwacht werden,
die nicht verboten werden kann,
die funktioniert, die schnell ist.
Das ist halt das, was Nano macht.
Nano ist eine Cryptocurrency,
die per By Design
nicht,
die per By Design keine Gebühren hat.
Nano kann keine Gebühren haben,
weil du es einfach nicht vorgesehen in dem Konzept,
du überweist Sachen
von einem Konto auf ein anderes
instant,
weil es halt nicht
diese Miner gibt.
Nano werden nicht gemeint, bei Nano
muss es kein Pool von Leuten geben, die Transaktionen bestätigen,
weil Nano ein sehr witziges Konzept
hat, dass jede Adresse
seine eigene Blockchain hat.
Jede Adresse?
Jede Adresse, jedes Konto quasi hat
eine eigene Blockchain.
Ich sage prinzipiell,
ich diese Transaktion hier vorhabe,
setze die in die Welt
nach draußen und es gibt so einen Konsensus
Algorithm, wo andere
Nano-Nodes sagen, ja, schaut
gut aus und nehmen das eben
an.
Jeder hat seinen, jedes Wallet
hat seine eigene Blockchain, aber die sehen
auch trotzdem alle. Die Nano-Nodes
sehen die anderen. Mich interessiert nur
meine eigene Blockchain, weil ich nur aus meiner eigenen Blockchain
meinen Kontostand
schlussfolgert,
weil ich dir einfach die Blockchain durchgehe
und dementsprechend mache ich
einen kleinen Proof-of-Work selber, indem ich
diese Transaktion generiere und einen Hash
für nur meinen Block, was
auf einem, keine Ahnung,
auf einem Embedded System
keine Millisekunden dauert,
weil es nur dieser eine kleine Hash ist.
Ich muss ja keinen Hash minen, ich muss diesen Hash generieren
für meinen Block
und dann gebe ich eben einer Nano-Node
diesen Block und sage, das ist der Block, den ich hier
gerade erstellt habe und da
wird dann eben dieser State gehalten,
dass dieser Block existiert
und distributed im Netzwerk.
Und die Nano-Node muss aber
kein Proof-of-Work machen,
um diesen Block zu verifien,
sondern dadurch, dass
so ein Consensus-Algorithm existiert,
also Nano-Nodes stimmen ab,
welche Transaktionen schlecht sind
und welche gut sind. Für gute müssen die gar nichts machen, für schlechte
können die aber sagen, nee, das da ist ein versuchter
Double-Spend, das ist keine gute Transaktion.
Und dadurch, dass die abstimmen
und sagen und einen Konsensus
erreichen, hast du halt irgendwann den Punkt, wo
gesagt wird, nein, das ist eine schlechte Transaktion,
Ja, die Transaktion, da ist gut. Und diese Abstimmung passiert halt dadurch, dass Nano-Wallets mit, also du hast halt mehr Stimmgewicht, je mehr Geld du hast. Und du kannst als Nano-Inhaber dein Stimmgewicht transferieren an eine Node deiner Wahl. Und es ist prinzipiell aktuell das Konzept, dass du versuchst, eine Node zu finden, die weniger als 1% Stimmgewicht hat, damit das schon möglichst dezentral ausgeglichen ist.
Das ist ja das Hauptproblem, was auch gerade bei Bitcoin irgendwie vor einiger Zeit mal angesprochen wurde, dass irgendwie mehr als 50% der Miner waren bereits irgendwo in China oder sowas.
Du kannst bei Bitcoin, dieses klassische Beispiel von einer 51%-Attack fahren, wenn du die Mehrheit des Netzwerks kontrollierst, kannst du letztendlich sagen, was sind valide Transaktionen.
Und witzigerweise, es gibt diese riesige Trade-Plattform Binance, die kommt glaube ich aus China, sind mittlerweile in Malta aus rechtlichen Gründen.
Die sind mit Abstand, also mit großem Abstand die größte Handelsplattform für Bitcoin.
mit großem, großem, großem Abstand.
Also mehr als Faktor 10.
Das war ein Vielfaches zu nächsten Exchange.
Wahrscheinlich sogar Faktor 100 oder was,
wenn ich das so richtig im Kopf habe.
Also ich habe jetzt keine Zahlen im Kopf,
gefährliches Halbwissen,
aber es war definitiv ein riesiger Abstand
zu nächsten Exchange.
Und Binance wurde vor nicht allzu langer Zeit mal gehackt.
Und da wurden ein paar hundert Millionen
in Bitcoin,
in US-Dollar in Bitcoin eben transferiert.
Und der Binance-CEO hat halt dann gesagt,
wir haben hier die Möglichkeit
und wir hätten technisch problemlos
die Möglichkeit gerade, wir können das
zurückrollen und unser Geld einfach
als nicht geklaut deklarieren.
Aber sie haben sich letztendlich
dagegen entschieden, also
um halt nicht das Vertrauen in Bitcoin zu erschüttern,
was sicherlich der richtige Schritt war an der Stelle,
aber allein die Tatsache, dass er das
ausgesprochen hat, dass der sich in die Öffentlichkeit
stellt und sagt, wir haben problemlos
diese Möglichkeit. Holy fuck.
Also das Vertrauen in Bitcoin ist damit schon erschüttern.
Ich habe es nicht verstanden, wie das bei Nano jetzt anders
sein soll,
dann kann das gleiche Problem
Du könntest prinzipiell das gleiche Problem einer 51%
Attack haben, beziehungsweise sogar ein bisschen
weniger, weil du nicht ganz so viel kontrollieren musst,
aber dafür
musst du halt auch diese Masse
mitbringen. Und
das Problem hat jede Cryptocurrency.
Die Cryptocurrencies bestehen alle darauf irgendwie,
dass du entweder
was bestätigst durch Arbeit oder durch
Proof of Stake oder durch
Consensus Algorithm, dass du halt irgendwie
festmachst, wer trifft letztendlich die Entscheidung
Entscheidungen werden durch Cryptography
auf die Allgemeinheit verteilt. Das ist das
generelle Grundprinzip von
vernichtlicher Cryptocurrency. Und das benutzt du jetzt irgendwie,
um deine Marta zu kaufen?
Wenn ich das könnte, wäre schön, aber
um den Satz noch den Gedanken zu
bringen, diese Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass das passiert wird,
umso kleiner, umso mehr das genutzt wird.
Achso, und jetzt hast du irgendwo so eine Node selber am Start.
Ich hause aktuell noch keine Node selber,
aber wäre relativ problemlos. Ich habe ja noch so ein Raspberry Pi
übrig. Kannst du problemlos machen,
dann kriegst du, dann
schicke ich dir direkt meine
Balance mit als die,
wo du hast so eine schöne Pi in Tastatur,
oh, die fliegen in der Hand halt.
Wie heißt das Ding nochmal?
Der Pi 400.
Oh, ist schon geil. Einfach eine Tastatur mit einem Rechner drin.
Ja, der ist doch schön.
Damit habe ich über Weihnachten, als ich keinen Linux-Rechner
zur Hand hatte, aber Linux entwickeln wollte,
habe ich auf dem Rust programmiert.
Sehr cool.
Es ging.
Ich muss trotzdem gestehen, ich fühle mich jetzt so ein bisschen
in der Zeit zurückversetzt, dass ich gerade von einem
Enthusiasten, was irgendwie über die neuste geile
Bitcoin-Alternative erklärt
bekommen. Das fühlt sich alles so ein bisschen
wie 2015 an.
Aber ich finde es halt mega cool,
weil es halt, dadurch, dass du halt
keine Transaktionsgebühren hast, dadurch, dass du
instant Transaktionen veröffentlichen kannst,
weil du diesen Blog einfach selber veröffentlichst,
ist es halt einfach, und dadurch, dass es
halt diesen Proof of Work nicht braucht,
hast du halt auch keinen Energieverbrauch.
Eine Transaktion von Bitcoin
kostet genauso viel Strom wie mit
einem Tesla einmal komplett durch die USA zu fahren.
Jede Transaktion, jede
einzelne Transaktion
kostet so viel Strom.
Ich kann mir gerade nicht vorstellen, wie dieser
Consensus-Algorithmus anderweitig
ohne Proof of Work funktionieren soll, dass es
sicher ist, ehrlich gesagt.
Ich kann das auch im Podcast nur bedingt
erklären. Auf nano.org findet man auf jeden Fall
mehr dazu. Es gibt auch ein paar gute Talks von den
Leuten, die das gebaut haben. Das White Paper ist auch
relativ kurz, 14 Seiten,
ist sehr eingänglich.
Also das führt mir jetzt doch ein bisschen vor Augen, warum es immer noch so viele Cryptocurrency oder Crypto-Blockchain-Buden gibt.
Wenn mich jemand mal auf einen Job anschreibt oder mich haben möchte, dann sagen die, du hast Rust gemacht, wir suchen jemanden für Blockchain XY.
Ist halt populär, da steckt halt auch unglaublich viel Geld drin.
Ich meine, du siehst ja allein daran, dass ein Bitcoin aktuell die 50.000-Dollar-Marke geknackt hat.
Da steckt unglaublich viel Geld drin in dem Ecosystem.
gerade in, jetzt gerade sind wir in so einem Markt,
wo alles da oben ist.
Die 50.000 Dollar Marke.
Ein Bitcoin ist, oh je, je, je.
45.000 Euro sind wir, glaube ich, heute früh.
Da gibt es doch jetzt garantiert so ein paar Nerd-Millionäre.
100 Pro, 100 Pro.
Ich beiß mir immer mehr in den Arsch.
Ja, ja, ja.
Und du denkst dir auch jedes Mal noch,
aber jetzt ist es wirklich zu spät.
Ja, eben.
Jetzt ist es wirklich zu spät.
Das war damals der Gedanke,
Bitcoin ist schon bei 30 Dollar,
jetzt ist es zu spät einzusteigen lassen.
Bitcoin ist schon bei 200 Dollar,
jetzt ist es viel zu spät einzusteigen.
Ich weiß, dass es mal bei 400 Euro war
und dann hat ein Kumpel gesagt,
ich habe mir eine Bitcoin für 400 Euro gekauft
und dann war es irgendwie so anderthalb Jahre lang
bei 250 und ich dachte mir,
der arme Kerl, der kriegt seine
250 Euro Differenz,
seine 150 Euro Differenz ja nie wieder
für diese eine Bitcoin.
Und dann hörst du halt irgendwie vor, ich glaube das letzte Mal
habe ich mich vor drei Jahren mit einem
EMA-Kollegen unterhalten, der irgendwie
für
1.000 Euro
Bitcoin gekauft hat, wo ich mir gedacht habe, echt,
ist das meines Jahr wirklich? Aber wenn der damals
für N.000 Euro Bitcoin gekauft hat und das
jetzt soweit ist, dann kann der sich dafür
ein Haus kaufen. Ich gehe auch fest davon aus,
also einerseits, dass ich, wenn
ich damals eingestiegen wäre bei 30 oder so,
wo ich erst mal auf den Kurs geschaut habe,
dann hätte ich das bei 200
easy alles schon verkauft.
Also ich hätte niemals bis jetzt gehalten. Und andererseits,
weil sowohl die ganze Zeit über Bitcoin
auch hergezogen wird, denkt sich
kein Mensch, dass das noch lange weitergeht.
Abgesehen davon, ich gehe fest davon aus,
dass wir aktuell genauso in einer Bubble sind wie 2018
und das gibt jetzt demnächst wieder einen Crash.
Aber abgesehen davon,
wir crashen nicht auf Null runter.
Für Bitcoin nicht, für die anderen sicherlich nicht.
Trotzdem sehe ich das hier als die Zukunft von dem,
was Bitcoin hätte sein wollen.
Es funktioniert einfach besser in jeder Hinsicht.
Die Cryptocurrency, mit der ich mein Brot kaufe.
Genau, du könntest damit problemlos eine Mate kaufen.
Das ist instant bestätigt.
Davon abgesehen, dass es niemand annimmt.
Davon abgesehen, dass es weniger Leute annehmen als Bitcoin annehmen aktuell.
Aber man kann es halt versuchen zu pushen und nur warten.
Und was ist jetzt das...
Apropos, sorry, ganz kurz, ich nochmal da reinstratsche.
Mastercard zum Beispiel hat sich schon nicht hinter Nano gestellt,
aber zumindest gesagt, dass Nano das wäre, womit wir unser Ding aufbauen.
Also du könntest auf jeden Fall die Acceptance irgendwo finden.
Und ich persönlich sehe hier viel Mehrwert.
Wie hieß eigentlich diese Cryptocurrency von Facebook nochmal?
Lira.
Libra.
Libra, stimmt.
Lira ist die ehemalige italienische
Erwährung.
Stimmt.
Das wäre auch dumm, eine Cryptocurrency, die
Euro heißt. Libra heißt mittlerweile
Diem, sehe ich gerade.
Okay.
Ja, aber ich bin schon ein bisschen in dem Hype, gerade die letzten Tage.
Das heißt, du hast jetzt irgendwie so ein paar
Nanos gekauft? Ich habe ein paar Nanos gekauft
und finde die Idee einfach super.
Und wenn du dir
ein Nano-Wallet auf deinem Namen
Natrium... Ja, klar, gib mir ein paar.
Lass mal runter, dann schicke ich dir ein paar Nanos rüber.
Das Problem bei Bitcoin war auch immer, ich wollte halt nicht meinen Namen damit verknüpft haben und musste immer zu irgendwem rennen, dem ich einen echten Zwani in der Hand drücke, damit der mir das, das warst immer du. Und da war es auch praktisch, wenn man das irgendwie, wenn man dann im ASCII die Marta damit verkauft und das in sein Bargeld sofort übersetzt hat, weil dann hat man einfach auf die Art und Weise diese Bitcoins eingesammelt.
Ja, absolut.
Aber ich sehe ein, dass irgendwie diese ganzen unterschiedlichen Cryptocurrencies alle irgendwie ihre eigenen Halsversprechen haben und dass sie bestimmt auch alle ganz cool umgesetzt sind.
Und es gibt halt auch manchmal, was für eine große Firma dahinter steht, wie Mastercard oder Facebook, obwohl Facebook, da bist du ja sofort unten durch, wenn du mit sowas ankommst.
Aber es ist eine große Firma, ja, du hast recht, da steckt halt direkt mehr dahinter.
Und es gibt aber irgendwie, und dann gab es noch Zcash und Ethereum und Sachen, die noch ganz andere Sachen, aber außer Bitcoin, ich stecke jetzt wirklich nicht drin, aber außer Bitcoin habe ich nicht den Eindruck, dass irgendwas irgendwie eine kritische Masse erreicht hätte.
Ethereum ist ein riesiges Ecosystem geworden.
Also es gibt haufenweise Altcoins,
die auf dem Ethereum-Konzept aufbauen,
beziehungsweise explizit auf der Ethereum-Blockchain aufbauen.
Ich muss gestehen,
ich habe das heute noch nicht hundertprozentig verstanden,
was Smart Contracts dir ermöglichen.
Ich weiß, dass die existieren.
Ich habe prinzipiell, glaube ich, das Konzept verstanden.
Aber da fehlt mir wirklich jegliche Weitsicht,
was das ermöglicht.
Ich wollte gerade vorschlagen,
vielleicht sollten wir mal jemanden einladen,
der uns das erklärt.
Auf der anderen Seite fühlt es sich auch an,
als ob es irgendwie fünf Jahre zu spät ist.
Auch, aber
wir sind immer noch nicht an dem Punkt, wo das halt
Gang und Gäbe ist und die normal...
Meine Eltern könnten nicht damit anfangen.
Mein Dad hat 100% schon mal von Bitcoin gehört,
aber da steckt niemand drin.
Ich bezahle momentan alles mit
Kreditkarte. Ich muss sagen, ich bin einer von den Leuten,
die sich darauf freuen, bald wieder mit
Bargeld bezahlen zu können, sobald das wieder geht.
Ich freue mich so, dass ich überall mittlerweile mit Apple Pay
zahlen kann. Selbst beim Bäcker
teilweise kann ich mit Apple Pay zahlen,
weil,
Bogen schlagen hier,
Nano hat das selbe Problem wie Bitcoin,
dass du halt keine Privacy hast.
Du hast halt diese öffentliche,
auch wenn es keine öffentliche Blockchain ist, sondern ein Blocklettes,
du hast halt die öffentliche Möglichkeit,
so nenn diese Seite,
nicht Lattes im Sinne von Salat, sondern Lattes.
Du hast ja wie so ein Block-Kristall.
Du hast einen Block-Salat, genau.
Ist ja auch ein Salat, passt sogar rechtlich gut.
Du kannst halt nachvollziehen,
aber dadurch, dass du keine Transaktionsgebühren hast,
kannst du halt dieses Mixing-Konzept besser fahren als bei Bitcoin,
wo du halt zum Mixen Transaktionsgebühren zahlen musstest.
Bei Bitcoin hast du einfach für jedes Dings,
hast du halt auf deiner einen App 35.000 Wallets
und für jeden Mist hast du einfach immer ein neues Wallet erzeugt.
Was ja auch super sinnvoll ist, auch im Nano-Konzept,
du willst eigentlich für jeden empfangende Transaktion
eine neue Adresse generieren.
Absolut sinnvoll.
Aber du kannst ja trotzdem nachvollziehen,
wo danach das Geld hinfließt.
Du kannst es halt verfolgen von Adresse zu Adresse.
Und wenn du bekannte Adressen hast, bekannte Knotenpunkte,
kannst du halt gewisse Aussagen darüber treffen.
Und deswegen kannst du das halt besser machen.
Du kannst besser Coins mixen,
sprich zwischen Adressen und herschieben und verteilen,
weil du halt keine Transaktionsgebühren hast.
Aber abseits davon,
du hast nicht dieses Privacy-Konzept.
Und das wollte ich gerade eben den Bogen sagen,
bei Apple Pay,
was ich da halt an Apple Pay so toll finde,
habe ich bestimmt im Podcast auch schon mehrfach gesagt,
dass Apple Pay mir für jede Zahlung
eine neue, kurzlebige,
ephemeral Kreditkartennummer generiert,
dass die Händler mich nicht checken könnten.
Das ist für mich das absolute Killer-Feature.
Das absolute Killer-Feature, dass ich halt
nicht trackbar bin für diese scheiß Händler,
wo ich was kaufe.
Was ja bereits, also bei
Kreditkarten normalerweise hast du keine
Privacy, aber du kannst
Privacy durch Obfuscation
obendrauf setzen.
Du hast halt Zahlungsdienstleister, die
Visa zum Beispiel
als Inhaber von dem ganzen Netzwerk
weiß jede Zahlung,
die ich mit Visa tätige.
Und Visa weiß wahrscheinlich immer noch letztendlich,
was meine Kreditkartenzahlungen sind, weil die ja trotzdem dadurch
laufen, aber die... Und Apple weiß es jetzt auch.
Apple weiß es auch, aber den
traue ich halt zumindest, also ich persönlich
traue denen, weil die halt nicht das Incentive meiner Meinung nach
haben, das zu tun,
das zu tracken und
daraus irgendwelchen blödsinnigen
Scheiß zu machen, aber die Zahlungsdienstleister
vor Visa noch,
die haben halt keine Möglichkeiten,
mich zu tracken. So was wie Wirecards zum Beispiel.
Die haben halt, das ist mir persönlich
echt viel wert, dass ich diesen Dienstag gerne nutze.
Und für mich hat es halt auch keine Nachhaltigkeit.
Was ich gerade sagen wollte, es gibt wahrscheinlich Schemes, mit denen du
so ein Ding wie Nano, was
prinzipiell funktioniert, aber nicht
anonym ist, durch Obfuscation
irgendwie, durch einen Aufsatz Apple Pay für
Nano oder sowas kannst du wahrscheinlich auch...
Wie gesagt, gerade weil du keine
Transaktionsgebühren hast, du kannst das Zeug rumherschieben,
du kannst Ping-Pong spielen mit deinem Geld, wie du möchtest.
Was ist denn der Incentive, so ein Ding zu
betreiben? Das ist halt oft gefragt,
der Incentive ist, dass du
das Netzwerk stabil halten möchtest und
wenn du halt selber Services betreibst, willst
natürlich auch eigene Notes betreiben, damit du halt,
weil du möchtest, dass das Netzwerk
lebt, weil du möchtest, dass das Netzwerk...
Das ist ja quasi, als ob du sagen würdest,
weil du möchtest, dass
E-Mail funktioniert, musst du deinen eigenen E-Mail-Server
betreiben. Aber nicht als Endkunde, sondern
als die Person, die E-Mail-Infrastruktur betreibt.
Und das ist ja da genauso richtig.
Google macht ja,
abgesehen davon, dass Google richtig viel
mit E-Mail kaputt gemacht hat,
hat Google ja nicht gesagt, wir nutzen
hier sonst wie einen E-Mail-Server, sondern
wir wollen ja unseren eigenen betreiben, weil wir unseren Kunden
das auch bieten wollen und die Möglichkeiten haben,
die Freiheiten haben, daran weiterzuentwickeln.
Die Leute, die dann zum Schluss ein Interesse daran haben,
einen Nano-Server,
Node zu betreiben,
sind dann sowas wie Mastercard und Apple Pay.
Die großen oder halt alle möglichen
kleinen Leute, die daran glauben oder
irgendwelche Zahlungsdienstleister oder
Läden selber. Im Prinzip kann das ja jeder machen.
Das Studentencafé um die Ecke, damit du
damit irgendwie dann deine Mate bezahlen kannst.
Alle können das machen. Das ist ja offen an der
Stelle schön und
gibt ja halt die Möglichkeit dazu. Es gibt natürlich auch noch andere
Kryptowährungen wie Monero zum Beispiel, die halt
eingebaut ein Privacy-Konzept haben.
Du kannst bei Monero nicht nachverfolgen, was mit
Bargeld passiert. Du siehst das nicht.
Das ist nicht öffentlich. Das ist trotzdem genauso
verifiziert und die Transaktionen sind fest in der Blockchain,
aber du siehst es, kannst das nicht
öffentlich nachverfolgen. Und das ist halt auch
mega gut. Mega gut.
Wenn sowas irgendwie in Nano vereinbart wäre, das wäre
das Kinderfeature. Naja, du müsstest das irgendwie kombinieren können.
Für mich ist das bloß wieder, also für mich führt sich das an
wie ein weiterer Schritt auf dem Weg
zur richtigen Kryptowährung, aber
es ist alles noch nicht das gleiche, weil ich
persönlich, wie gesagt, ich freue
mich schon drauf, wenn ich wieder Bargeld um mich werfen kann.
Einfach, weil
das wirklich das Anonymste ist, was du machen kannst.
Du hast physisches Geld in der Hand
und ich
habe schon, ich weiß, dass ich schon
bei Rewe den Korb an der Kasse
habe stehen lassen, weil ich kein Bargeld
dabei hatte.
Und dann bin ich aus dem Rewe ohne Korb raus,
habe Bargeld abgehoben, bin zurück,
habe meinen Korb wieder in die Hand genommen.
Nicht schlecht, nicht schlecht.
Aber Bargeld hat natürlich
eine andere Limitierung, die wir versuchen mit
ja auch zu gehen, dass du halt global Geld
verschickst.
Nein, damit du, was? Achso, das meinst du.
Aha, das meine ich gar nicht mal.
Aber du,
Kryptokollern, die kannst du ja global verschicken.
Und hast du schon mal versucht, jemanden
in Asien Geld zu schicken?
Das ist scheißschwierig.
Ja, deswegen gibt es ja auch sowas so
Wire Money.
Ja, aber das heißt, du hohe Rente, Gebühren und das dauert
Zeit. Das stimmt definitiv.
Leute, die versuchen, das war so ein schönes Beispiel irgendwo,
was ich heute gelesen habe.
Und dann gibt es natürlich auch Länder, wo die Infrastruktur einfach nicht da ist.
Deshalb sowas wie Diem, Libra oder sowas halt für afrikanische Länder ganz gut ist,
wo jeder ein Handy hat, aber sonst grundlegende Infrastruktur,
wie zum Beispiel ATMs oder sowas, einfach nicht da sind.
Ich habe gerade eine Push-Notification bekommen.
Das war exakt das nächste Thema, was ich noch ganz kurz ansteigen wollte.
So wie es Dogecoin, Dogecoin, wie auch immer, für Bitcoin gibt, als Meme-Coin,
gibt es für Nano auch eine extra, es gibt einen Nano-Fork,
Der heißt Banano.
Ah, das war das, was du da...
Das ist die Meme-Coin-Alternative zu Nano.
Nutzt exakt dasselbe Konzept.
Es ist wirklich ein Nano-Fork.
Du kannst dieselben Adressen,
bloß mit einem anderen Präfix.
Und die Nano-Leute haben aber so viel Spaß.
Du kannst ja Nano nicht meinen.
Du kannst Banano auch nicht meinen.
Du kannst kein Geld erzielen.
Was heißt Fork in der Cryptocurrency,
wo eh jeder seine eigene Blockchain betreibt?
Es ist ein anderes Netzwerk.
Ein separates Netzwerk.
Es gibt schon noch Netzwerke.
Also du hast ja genau, diese Nano-Nodes reden ja miteinander.
Du willst ja, dass deine Nano-Payments, was ich dir schicke,
auch bei dir ankommt.
Und nur weil du eine eigene Blockchain hast,
heißt das ja nicht, dass das, also du musst ja irgendwie,
das Netzwerk muss ja trotzdem miteinander reden.
Und Banano ist ein eigenes Netzwerk,
aber du kannst ja Banano nicht meinen, also du kannst
nicht Rechenleistungen bereitstellen und dafür bezahlt werden.
Die Banano-Leute sind aber
so witzig und sagen, wir wollen
das aber trotzdem machen, deswegen haben
wir ein Folding-at-home-Team gestartet
und Leute, die
die mit unserem Team, also Falling at Home,
dieses Projekt, wo man Proteine falten kann
für Covid-Research oder Alzheimer oder was auch immer,
Leute, die in unserem Team,
in dem Banano-CC-Team dazu beitragen,
zu Falling at Home, kriegen, je nachdem,
wie viele Punkte sie generieren, von uns Banano geschenkt.
Quasi. Also quasi,
meinst du Banano, ohne Banano zu meinen?
Ich habe gerade die Push-Node für Kerchen geschickt,
dass ich gerade Banano geschickt bekommen habe,
weil mein Rechner zu Hause gerade für Falling at Home
Covid-Moleküle faltet.
Nicht schlecht, nicht schlecht.
Ich möchte an dieser Stelle dazu noch hinzufügen,
dass ich dieses Jahr zum allerersten Mal,
seitdem ich in diese Wohnung eingezogen bin,
aufgrund des Lockdowns
und zum ersten Mal eine Stromnachzahlung machen musste.
Bei uns aber auch so.
Im Jahr davor habe ich 50 Euro rausbekommen
und dieses Jahr habe ich 100 Euro draufgezahlt.
Ich hoffe, die Rückzahlung der Steuererklärung
rentiert sich da zumindest ein bisschen,
um das wieder auszugleichen.
Aber ja, das ist echt scheiße,
dass man die ganze Zeit auch mit Arbeitsgeräten daheim ist
und die ganze Zeit...
Ja, ja.
Das macht sich echt bemerkbar.
So, geil. Zwei coole Themen gehabt.
Wollen wir noch auf
das waren jetzt die ganze Zeit
Picks, der Rest sind nur so
Kleinigkeiten. Ich hätte noch einen Pick
zum Thema TypeScript.
Na klar. Und zwar hat ein
Kollege von mir neulich
eigentlich eher für unsere neuen
Teammitglieder, aber ich finde es eigentlich
genauso spannend, definitiv, ein Projekt
rumgeschickt, das heißt Type Challenges
für TypeScript.
Sind das Code Challenges?
Das sind Code-Challenges, aber halt rein für TypeScript.
Und ich kann dir da mal kurz ein Beispiel zu aus...
Ich bin ja ein großer Freund von TypeScript-Meta-Programming.
Ich mache gerne geilen Scheiß.
Gib mir einen Typen, der als Parameter eine Klasse hat
und alle möglichen Werte von diesem Typ sind dann die Public-Methoden
von dieser Klasse, die mit A anfangen.
Das geht mit TypeScript, ja.
Coole Sprache.
Und hier gibt es die Kategorie
Easy, Medium, Hard, Extreme.
Und bei Easy gibt es dann so Sachen, die genauso
bereits in der Standardbibliothek
so als Convenience-Typen vorkommen.
Sowas wie Pick.
Gib mir einen Typen, da gibst du als ersten
Parameter einen Struct rein
und hinten Keys. Und dann hast du
quasi als Ergebnis nur das Subset
von dem Ding, was du vorne reingegeben hast,
wo nur diese Keys drin vorkommen.
Es gibt einen Typen, der heißt First of Array.
Wirklich, du gibst einen Array rein
und der gibt dir als rückgabewerten den Typen
dem ersten Element von dem Array.
Bei Medium gibt es dann sowas, ist auch immer noch
in der Standard-
in der Standard-Bibliothek drin.
Return-Type
gibt mir eine Funktion
und ich sage dir, was der Return-Type davon ist.
Und bei
Extreme gibt es dann sowas wie
Camel Case
oder Capitalized Words, was
alles so Sachen sind, die erst mit TypeScript
4.1 möglich wurden.
Oder sagst, gib mir
einen String-Literal und ich gebe dir
die gekämmelkaste Variante
von dem String, literal.
Und das ist
äh, und bei Extreme
hab ich noch gar nicht mehr angefangen. Da gibt's dann
Currying auf Type-Ebene.
Also ich hab
leider noch keine Zeit gehabt, die tatsächlich zu machen. Ich hab mal
einen mit einem Kollegen zusammen
gemacht, angefangen, dieses Return-Type.
Da fängst du dann an mit dem Infer-Keyword,
was du sonst nirgendwo benutzt, um die Sachen
zu machen. Das ist schon spannend. Also das ist
ein bisschen geiles Zeug. Wo stehen die
Zahlen?
Die Zahlen vor den ganzen Challenges?
Oh, das sind, glaube ich, du kannst Solutions einreichen.
Ach, das sind die Menge an Solutions?
Ich schätze mal, ich weiß nicht,
wofür steht jetzt hier 15?
Oder die sind durchsortiert?
Ich weiß nicht, wofür die Zahlen stehen.
Egal.
Sind die fortlaufend?
Nee, eben nicht, deswegen wundere ich mich.
Da sind 500 irgendwas, Deep Object Unique.
Wer weiß.
Sehr witzig, aber finde ich künftig.
Mein Type-System gibt ja unglaubliche Möglichkeiten,
da wirklich auf Zypsystem-Ebene
Spaß zu haben. Und du bist ja auch, also du hast
in der letzten Folge oder mir schon mal ein paar
Sachen erzählt, die
in irgendeiner Folge, was da so alles
für abstruser Shit auch
drin ist. Ja, es hat den Namen,
ich fände es cool, dass die Sprache den Begriff
Type im Namen hat, ehrlich gesagt.
Was ich hier am nützlichsten fand,
war fast, wenn du dir so ein Beispiel
aufmachst, dann hast du hier
so eine Aussage, die du erfüllen musst. Du kannst hier sagen
Take the Challenge
da und dann geht dieses TypeScript Playground
Dings auf.
Und du hast, hier unten
steht einfach, wird typedefiniert Cases,
was ein Tuple ist von
Expect, Expect, Expect, Expect und dann
Equal und dann der erste Parameter ist,
was einfach hart hingeschrieben ist und das
zweite muss deine Lösung sein.
Und dann gibt es wirklich hier aus der
Standardbibliothek, aus den
Utility-Types von
Type-Challenges ein, diese beiden
Typen sind Equal.
Und das
habe ich schon länger gesucht, so Static Assert.
für TypeScript, wo du sagen kannst, was ich hier
ausdrücke und was ich da ausdrücke, ist
das gleiche. Wir haben nämlich
neulich, wir benutzen TypeScript für
ein Protokoll zwischen Server und Client
und hatten erst nur Typen hingeschrieben,
um diese Payload-Messages
zu verifizieren. Wenn beide Seiten
die gleiche Library
für das Protokoll benutzen, dann hat uns
das im ersten Schritt gereicht, dass die
valide Nachrichten hin und her schicken.
Hat dann irgendwann nicht mehr gereicht und wir
wollten
gibt es ein Framework, das heißt Zot,
da kannst du in JavaScript oder in TypeScript
so eine Art
JSON-Schema schreiben, wo du einfach
schreibst, hier ist jetzt ein Inam,
hier ist ein Struct und da muss
vorne, der erste String,
der Name darf nicht länger als 10 Zeichen sein
oder irgend sowas.
Dann kriegst du wirklich einen JavaScript-Validator,
der das prüft.
Und
du kannst dir dann aus diesen Validatoren
kannst du sagen, gib mir mal den Typen zu diesem Validator
und dann kriegst du,
den kannst du dann benutzen. Das ist dann allerdings
wirklich hergeleitet von einem Stück
ausgeführtem Code, was du irgendwo
hingeschrieben hast. Und dann guckst du so drauf
und sagst dir so, ist das wirklich identisch
zu den Typen, die ich da vorher hingeschrieben
hatte, wo ich das TypeScript lesen konnte?
Und war ich mir nicht ganz so sicher,
ob ich es machen wollte, aber wir brauchten halt Validatoren.
Und dann irgendwann habe ich gesehen, ah, es gibt mir diese
Equal-Funktion, oder diesen Equal-Type.
Sehr schön. Dann habe ich also quasi die alten
Typen aus dem Git nochmal wieder hergestellt
und habe einfach eine Datei gemacht, wo nur
validiert wird, dass die alten Typen und die
neuen Typen äquivalent sind.
Das sind so
die nützlichen Kleinigkeiten,
die man aus diesen Type-Challenges
zumindest rauszuholen kann. Und man kann sehr viel über das Type-Script-Typ-System
lernen.
Du wärst eh die Person, die ich für sowas schon konsultieren würde.
Ja, ich muss mal wieder mehr über Rust
erzählen, ehrlich gesagt. Ich rede in letzter Zeit viel zu viel
über Type-Script in diesem Podcast.
Also, das ist so viel zum Thema Type-Challenges.
Nee, cool.
Ich glaube, ich verzichte immer auf meine Picks.
der Zeit zuliebe.
Diesen einen Rust-Pick,
den musst du unbedingt noch erwähnen.
Ach, nur weil Rust im Namen steckt?
Du hast gesagt, du hast einen Rust-Pick,
den ich nicht kenne.
Das finde ich spannend.
Rust-Scan ist Nmap in Rust neu
für ultraschnelles Port-Scanning.
Also so wirklich
ultra-ultraschnell.
So tausende Scans pro Sekunde.
Das ist
sehr effizient.
Und natürlich, wenn du es auf
der Geschwindigkeit machst, auch sehr einfach
für die Gegenseite zu sehen, was du
da gerade tust, wenn du 65.536
Ports in 10 Sekunden
durchgescannt hast, aber
Ist das wirklich das Logo von
Homebrew? Das ist das Logo von Homebrew. Krass.
Aber
Vascan ist eine schicke
Utility. Hat auch eine schöne,
bunte CLI. So was mag ich ja.
Cool.
Ich glaube, damit haben wir jetzt auch genug
zweieinhalb Stunden Folge
ist okay, kann man machen.
Ja, kann man machen.
Danke fürs Zuhören. Ja, vielen Dank fürs Durchhalten.
Das war
akronomisierbar Folge
47.
Wir müssen uns noch irgendwas für die 50. Folge
direkt näher.
Dieses Jahr definitiv.
Definitiv davon ausgehen.
Sehr wahrscheinlich, aber solche Folgen
in die Zukunft. Vielleicht ist es sogar bald,
aber sie ist hoffentlich mindestens dieses Jahr.
Ist sie noch im Lockdown? Vermutlich.
Keine Prognosen darüber.
Ja, vielen
vielen Dank, dass ihr, vor allem
vielen vielen Dank an alle Leute im
akronomisierbar Matrix.
Wir haben ja bis dato immer gesagt,
ihr erreicht uns auf Twitter, aber eigentlich finden wir es viel
geiler, wenn ihr unseren Matrix-Channel joint
und deswegen packen wir den Link
zu dem Matrix-Channel noch in unsere Show-Notes
rein. Macht mal, ist cool.
Coole Leute da.
Und bis dahin hört
fleißig weiter Podcasts
und der nächste Podcast in eurem Ketchup
bereits in 3, 2, 1, 2.